COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN A MERCHANT C.
M. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AT BASE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY.
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
IN THE CAPITAL WITH NONE OF
ARMENT COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR
DISSIPATING REMOTELY TODAY. AND
THE SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME ARE
SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER
PATROL BOAT M. PAN SENATE-ROOM
MCGUIRE IS ABSENT TODAY TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. REMOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO THE L.
ONE TEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. TO RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT FOR IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE AND YOU DID AND YOU
WERE NOT READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING ****
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THE CONNECTION MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE. TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
SO AGAIN PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT. TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TO BILLS ON
CONSENT AND THE TWO BILLS THAT
ARE ON CONSENT PART. ITEM FIVE
SB SEVEN TWO TWO AND ITEM SIX
SB SIX SEVENTY THREE. BEFORE WE
HEAR THE PRESENTATION OF BILLS
WITH THE FELLOWSHIP QUORUM
MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE
PHOTO ABOVE HERE THE TROUBLE
HERE COURTESY OF CORTEZ THE
HERE DALY YOUR DAILY HERE
GLAZER. LASER HAIR MCGUIRE PAN
AM HERE. THE ROOM CONSULTANT A
WELCOMING GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
BEING BRIGHT AND EARLY AND ALL
FIRST AUTHORS HERE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FIRST DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MOTIONS WERE MADE BY SENATOR
PAN ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CONSENT CALENDAR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE- CHILL ABODE HI
THE TROUBLE BOGOTA COURTESY ALL
RIGHT FOR I DELI AYE DALY AYE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER BY MCGUIRE
PAN HI CAN I THE SECOND THING
GALLAGHER HAS BEEN APPROVED
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME SENATOR ALAN PLEASE
PROCEED WITH S. T. R. WARREN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT'S A
NICE TO BE BACK IN MY OLD HOME
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
SYSTEMS AND GOOD FRIENDS- THIS
BILL CALLS ON PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO SUPPORT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES BOZELL TO
FORGIVE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR
STUDENT BORROWERS ACROSS THE
NATION AND I SHOULD BURKE I
SHOULD ALSO CLARIFY THE
RESOLUTION IS NOT A BILL IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S. AN STR ONE. AS YOU
EVERYBODY HERE KNOWS THE
CLASSIFIER. IS RISING.
SIMULTANEOUSLY LOAN TO AND I
STAY ACROSS THE SKY. INCREASING
100% OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
THINK ABOUT THAT MEMBERS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY- OVER FORTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE OWED MORE THAN
ONE POINT SEVEN TRILLION
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
IN CALIFORNIA- OVER THREE
MILLION BORROWERS- HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AN
AVERAGE OF NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER BAR BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME THAT HAVE FAR HIGHER THAN
THAT. WHAT IS THAT MEANS
STUDENT LOAN DEBT BURDENS OUR
ECONOMY. IT DELAYS THE ABILITY
AND SOMETIMES LITERALLY STOPS
SOMEONE FROM ALTERNATELY BUYING
A HOME. STARTING A BUSINESS
REACHING OTHER IMPORTANT
FINANCIAL MILESTONES. WHEN
DEPUTIES REPORTEDLY IMPACTS
STUDENTS WHOSE FAMILIES. I
CAN'T HELP THEM PAY FOR
EDUCATION WHICH OF COURSE
EXACERBATES- FOR MANY LOW
INCOME EXACERBATING
INEQUALITIES FOR MANY LOW
INCOME AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS FOR THOSE. FAMILIES
THAT ARE YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE ON THE
DEBT. IN THE FIRST PLACE SO.
OUR OUR OUR PRESIDENT HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MILLIONS
AND WE'D LIKE TO URGE HIM. TO
CANCEL FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT. I HERE
WITH ME TESTIFIED SUPPORTER
CATHERINE WELL BACK DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND CIVIL
RIGHTS COUNCIL FOR THE STUDENT
BORROWER PROTECTION CENTER. IN
ALLEN CALDERON WHOSE EXTERNAL
BY THE PRESIDENT. OF ASSOCIATE
STUDENT BODY AT UC IRVINE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN WE WILL
GO TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT EACH
WITNESS A TO OUR WHICH- WE'D
WITNESSES EACH WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. SO WE WILL START WITH
A DOCTOR WILL BACK WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU OPEN
YOUR OWN VEHICLE MARC AND GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE- MEANING THAT
WHILE BACK AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF ADVOCACY AT THE BAR
PROTECTION CENTER. I'M HERE TO
HELP YOU FIND SUPPORT AS CHAIR
ONE I'M IN THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF PRESIDENT BINDING
CAN'T PLACE THE EXACT AND I
REALLY THOUGHT I GO WHAT- WE
JUST TURNED OUT THAT THE- I.
ALL RIGHT CRISIS- BUT YOU WERE
RECEIVED BORROWED COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK NINETEEN OF
OUR DISPROPORTIONATE STRUGGLING
BUT HE KNEW THAT- WHAT WE. SEE
IS THAT. I'M ON AVERAGE BY OF
OUR- TELEPHONE CALL COULD WELL
SHE. EIGHTY NINE ONE MORE DECK
PAY FOR SCHOOL INSTEAD WE THEY
LEAVE- HOLD MORE DATA CUT
OPPORTUNITY TO WALK- THERE LIKE.
AND SO- TALK AND LOOKING AND
ACT AND THE CON OF EACH WE CAN
OVERLOOK HOW ARE COULD NOT. AND
THE DEBT DIRECTLY- SH IF YOU
COULD PREVENT THE. RACIAL ARE
GETTING. REALLY CAN MEAN
PROVIDE. MY NEEDED SIMILAR HELP
PEOPLE DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND
ALL THE ANSWER LIKE PRETTY GOAL
THREE. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT-
YOU KNOW OF OUR THE COLOR BE
REALLY GREAT BENEFIT FROM-
DOCTOR GIVEN POLICY IN REALLY
LOOK AT HOW TO ATTACK HIM. THE
MEANS THE NARRABRI WHILE GAP
AND AGAIN I HERE THE CORE AND-
AS ONE THANK YOU FOR THE ARE.
TO ASK THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER. UNDER SECRETARY
OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
STUDENT LOAN DEBT. IF YOU EVER
RISING COST OF TUITION AND
HOUSING AND THEREFORE HIGHER
AMOUNT OF LOANS NEEDED HIGHER
EDUCATION IS BECOMING A DREAM
DEFERRED FOR MANY STUDENTS
INCLUDING MYSELF WE ARE TAUGHT
FROM A YOUNG AGE THAT ATTENDING
COLLEGE IS A NECESSITY. FOR
MANY STUDENTS FROM A LOW INCOME
BACKGROUND THAT IS VERY MUCH
THE MENTALITY BUT OFTEN NOT A
REALITY BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
COST OF ATTENDANCE. IS THAT THE
BURDEN BEYOND THE COMPLETION OF
OUR EDUCATION ALL OF THE STORE
CAREER AND CAN BE A HUGE
OBSTACLE TO HOME OWNERSHIP OR
STARTING A FAMILY. STUDENT LOAN
DEBT CAN BE AND OFTEN IS A
LIFELONG ISSUE THIS IS NOT JUST
AN EDUCATION ISSUE IT'S AN
ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUE.
FORGIVING ARE CANCELING STUDENT
LOAN DEBT IT'S NOT JUST A
COMMITMENT TO THE STUDENTS
EDUCATION THE COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WHO HAVE BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF BY PREDATORY LENDERS
CANCELING STUDENT LOAN DEBT. IS
AN ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUE. WELL
SOME DON'T FORGET PRO ALREADY.
THEY ARE OFTEN FAR TOO LIMITED
TO CERTAIN FIELDS OR LACK
GUIDANCE ON MANY PEOPLE MAKE
THE DECISION TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT SHOULD
AUTOMATICALLY BE PLACED ON THE
PATH TO DEBT FORGIVENESS. AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS NEED TO
ALSO BE FAR MORE EXPENSIVE. IN
THE STUDENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE SET TO BENEFIT FROM TIS
DEBT FORGIVENESS THAT AMOUNTS
TO MILLIONS OF DEGREES.
EDUCATED MINDS AND DREAMS
ACCOMPLISHED. SENATORS ARE
FAMILIES ARE RIGHT WHEN THEY
TELL US EDUCATION ESPECIALLY
HIGHER EDUCATION IS A
NECESSITY. PLEASE HELP US
ACHIEVE EQUITABLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TO NOW GO TO
SUPPORT CARE ROOM FORTY TWO- OH
THREE. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
THEY'RE- SEEING NONE WILL NOW
GO TO OVER TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF S. J. R. ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. T. R.
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. J. R. ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ANALYST LIKE WE HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN Q. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS OF PRISCILLA Q. DOLLARS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU. FORMER
MANAGER AS WE GOT ON THE OTHER
LINE NUMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN. MY NUMBER SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS
TIFFANY MARC REPRESENTING CAL
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT IN CROWD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALRIGHT IS
ANOTHER TIME AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO ONE I THINK YOU THINK
ABOUT A MODERATOR ALL RIGHT WE
WILL DO THE SAME PROCESS IN
REGARD TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED
WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE HERE WE
WILL NOW GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NONE.
MATAMATA OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SJR
ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
S. T. R. ONE. CHRISTMAS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. T. R. ONE.
CONTRACT ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW.
AND AT THE TIME AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
DOES THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE YES GO AHEAD
SENATOR DOLLY I JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT- SO I LOOK THIS
BILL OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THAT. IF
STUDENT AT IS SOMETHING VERY
HARD TO PAY BACK BUT YOU ALSO
RECEIVE EDUCATION. AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT HIGHER ED GET
USUALLY TYPICALLY PAY MORE
WE'VE SEEN ALL THE STATISTICS
OF THAT. THEY DID THE DAY- SO
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR THIS MONEY
THAT HAS BEEN LOANED OUT AND
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT PAY ARE
US. AND PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T GO
TO COLLEGE THE END UP PAYING
THAT BILL FOR THOSE REASONS I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
PIECE OF THIS SJR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING SENATE-
BY SURE RESIDENCIA A BOOK OR
TROUBLED. SO IN CONTEXT- MY
PARENTS WERE IMMIGRANTS AND LOW
INCOME. I THEY DID NOT HAVE THE
FULL ABILITY TO. HELP VERY MUCH
WITH MY COLLEGE TUITION. I
ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH GRANTS
AND SCHOLARSHIPS IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO PAY IN A WORK THROUGH
COLLEGE. I HAD DEBT. WHEN I
FINISHED SCHOOL. AND WORK
TOWARDS FINISHING IN PAYING
THAT DEBT OUT. AND IT BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I. DID NOT
HARDIS VERY MUCH FINANCIAL
LITERACY HAD THE BASICS BUT I
DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND-
REALLY HAVE THAT FINANCIAL
LITERACY THAT I THINK WOULD
HAVE BEEN MARIN POWERING ON ON
MY END. AND THIS BRINGS EIGHTY
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS BILL
OR THIS RESOLUTION THIS THIS
LETTER THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEND TO THE- TO THE PRESIDENT.
AND THEN MAYBE. SORT OF START
THINKING ABOUT CERTAIN
QUESTIONS AND ONE. THE COST OF
SCHOOLING OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN IN IN OUR NATION IN
CALIFORNIA EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
WHICH GOES ALONG WITH THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A VERY HIGH COST
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL AND THAT IS A HUGE CONCERN
FOR ME. ON ON MANY LEVELS AS TO
WHAT CAUSES THE RISE IN THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA-
IN THAT- AND ALSO. WITH THE
COST OF LIVING CALIFORNIA BEING
SOME EXTREMELY HIGH. THE
RAMIFICATION EFFECTS OF THAT IN
IN OUR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T LIVE THEY NEED A
SAFETY NET AND SO THEY LOOK AT
GOVERNMENT IF THAT THE KEY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES FAMILIES CAN
MEET THOSE NEEDS TO LOOK AT
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS. AND AND THEN THE
GOVERNMENT LOOKS TO US TO
TAXPAYERS WHICH WE ARE ALL
TAXPAYERS AND- IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER WEEK SOME OF US BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN OTHERS BUT
EVERYBODY PAYS INTO. THESE
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
PAY. FOR THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
GOVERNMENT IS USING TO YOU TO
PAY FOR THESE FOR THESE ISSUES
SO ONE WAY OR ANOTHER WE'RE ALL
STILL PAYING FOR- WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS BASICALLY HELPING
PEOPLE OUT WITH. SO MAYBE THINK
ABOUT THAT IT ALSO MADE ME
THINK ABOUT- AB. ALL THE NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS SO IN EDUCATION
AND BUDGET WE'VE BEEN APPROVING
A LOT OF FINANCIAL HELP. WITH
GRANTS AND THE ABILITY TO. HELP
STUDENTS OUT FINANCIALLY TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH SCHOOL SO
THERE'S A LOT OF HELP ALREADY
IN PLACE. FOR PEOPLE THAT CAN'T
MEET THEIR NEEDS. SO I I'M A
LITTLE HESITANT- ON THIS
ENDEAVOR JUST BECAUSE- WE
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE A LOT OF
SAFETY NETS FOR STUDENTS AND
THAT'S NOT SAYING THAT IT'S NOT
ENOUGHIT MADE IT COULD NOT
ALWAYS BE ENOUGH- BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS. GONE THROUGH
THE SAMETHING OF GOING TO
SCHOOL NOT HAVING A LOT OF
MONEY I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
LIVE ON RAW MAN. AND YOU KNOW
FROZEN VEGETABLES- TO MAKE IT
TO THE TO THE END OF THE WEEK
OUR TO THE OF THE MONTH. I
COMPLETELY GET THIS BUT WE
ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF THINGS IN
PLACE TO HELP OUR STUDENTS. AND
WE'VE BEEN APPROVING THAT SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE WE'VE BEEN
APPROVING A LOT AND I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN IN PLACE A LOT OF
EFFORTS IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE LINE AT
THE END OF THE OF THE OF THE OF
THE CONSIDERATION THAT I HAD
WHEN I WAS REVIEWING THIS WAS
THE FACT THAT. WE ARE ALL STILL
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR THIS.
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER THIS.
CONTINUES TO ADAM TO OUR BOTH
OUR- OUR FEDERAL DEBT. WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY OUR KIDS. THE
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT-
THEIR KIDS KIDS WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT. AND I'M
NOT SURE WITH THE TOTAL THAT IS
RIGHT NOW AT THE- AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BUT- I'M
THINKING. CAN WE TRULY A FOR
THIS RIGHT NOW IS THE WISEST
PLACE. WHERE CAN WE FIND OTHER
WAYS TO MAKE IT MORE
AFFORDABLE- AS FAR AS- MAYBE.
LOOKING AT THE COST OF
SCHOOLING- AND THEN. RE
EVALUATING- WHAT IS IT HOW MUCH
IS IT THAT WE HAVE TO- EXPECT
FROM OUR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEIR AND- BUT IT'S A
TEAM EFFORT. SO FOR THOSE
VARIOUS REASONS AND SO FORTH
JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE REYES WE'RE- WE'RE
WE STILL RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
STAT. IT'S BEEN PAID OUT. WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER AND- AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY PAID DIRECTLY. INDIRECTLY
THEY'LL STILL HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT- AND WITH
INTEREST AT AMUCH HIGHER LAYER
AT. AT AND FURTHER. DOWN THE
LINE- IMPACTS SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS- I. E. I RESPECT. YOUR
INTENT. BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
THIS OVERALL IN THE LONG TERM.
IS SOLVING THE ATTIC THE
CRISIS- OR THE- THE FINANCIAL-
IMPACT THIS HAS. ON OUR
STUDENTS SO. I WILL
RESPECTFULLY NOT SUPPORT THIS
AT THE MOMENT- BUT I DO.
RESPECT YOUR INTENDED TRYING TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS- IN MY OF
TODAY'S- ECON. AND THE- OF
LIVING CAL. THANK YOU FOR-
ANYONE ELSE. BEFORE ELSE THE
CLOSE CENTER AND ONE I WOULD
JUST SAY- YOU NORTH DE IS HIGH.
BUT I WOULD I LOVE SEE US
SOMETHING THAT CAUSES OUR DEBT
GO UP HELP. STUDENTS THAT HELPS
ORDINARY WORKING FOLKS FOR SO
MANY YEARS WE HAVE INCREASED
OUR FEDERAL DEBT BY GIVING TAX
BREAKS TO MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES WHAT'S UP THE
WORKING CLASS SO ON I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
IF YOU WOULD LIKE PLEASE CLOSE.
I BY BEVERAGE IT DOES COME AS
MANAGER AND I WILL JUST SAY
THAT THAT- ALL THE WONDERFUL
SUPPORTS THAT I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT CENTER- WHAT WILL HELP
THE NEXT GENERATION OF STUDENTS
COMING THROUGH BUT THERE IS A
WHOLE. GROUP OF COHORT STUDENTS
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE ADVANTAGES
OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE REALLY BEING IMPACTED
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT
ON THE ECONOMY IT DOES HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY WHEN
THEY'RE UNABLE TO. HAVE ENOUGH
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD
SAVINGS TO PULL TOGETHER A DOWN
PAYMENT- TO BE ABLE TO START A
BUSINESS AND- SO. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE.
HI OF COURSE IT IS JUST A
RESOLUTION IT'S ONLY URGING- WE
APPROVE FEDERAL ACTION- BUT IT
DOES PUT US ON RECORD IN
SUPPORT OF. OF A SERIOUS
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO ADDRESS THIS.
THIS LOAN BIRD AND THAT IS THAT
IS JUST. ENORMOUS AND AUNTS AND
STIFLING. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU CENTER
OUR MEMBERS TO HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE REMOTE OUR MOTION
FOR MADE BY SENATOR GLAZERS.
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE NUMBER ONE S. J.
R. ONE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
LEYVA. HI LEYVA HI OCHO ABODE
NO. PICTURE BOOK NO. COURTESY
HI. COURTESY I DALY BILL. KELLY
NO GLAZER. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
PAN HI. AN HIGH. BUT BILLS OUT
FORTY TO FIFTY MEMBERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS WERE GONNA
NOW MOVED TO CENTER GLAZER SAID
REPLACING YOU JUST PERCENT FROM
YOUR SEAT TODAY THANK YOU.
CENTER GLAZER HAS SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. BUT
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH AIMS TO
INCREASE GRADUATION RATES FOR
STUDENTS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THE
BILL'S FOLK. IS DOING ACT FOR
ALL STUDENTS. SINCE FIRST PUT
INTO LAW IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM HAS SERVED
ALMOST NINETEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AT PARTICIPATING
CSU'S. THE STUDENTS RECEIVE
PRIORITY REGISTRATION AND
ADVANCED ADVISING TOOLS NEEDED
TO HELP STUDENTS GRADUATING
EITHER FOUR YEARS. OR FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS IN
TWO YEARS. FOR THE TWO THIRDS
OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THIS PROGRAM.
ARE PELL RECIPIENTS ACCORDING
TO DATA PROVIDED BY THE CSU.
AND ABOUT HALF OF THOSE WHO
HAVE PARTICIPATED ARE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
HISTORICALLY HOWEVER THE CSU
HAS STRUGGLED TO CLOSE STUBBORN
EQUITY GAPS BETWEEN STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND WHITE STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY THE CSU FOR YOUR
GRADUATION GAP BETWEEN FRESHMEN
STUDENTS WHO IDENTIFY AS
AFRICAN AMERICAN NATIVE
AMERICAN OR LATINO AND THEIR
WHITE PEERS IS AT TEN POINT
FIVE PERCENTAGE POINTS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE NINE
POINT 2% FOR YOUR GRADUATION
GAPS BETWEEN TELL RECIPIENTS
AND THOSE WHO DID NOT RECEIVE
PELL GRANTS. IMPROVING
EDUCATION OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
THOSE FROM ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS IS
ESSENTIAL TO GENERATE UPWARD
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND ENSURE A
PROSPEROUS STATE. THIS BILL
WILL TARGET THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM TO LOW INCOME
FIRST GENERATION AND
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
PUTTING THOSE STUDENTS ON A
PATH TO GRADUATING WITHIN FOUR
YEARS. WITH ME TODAY TO DISCUSS
THE BILL IS HE PETRON A
CALIFORNIA PROMISE STUDENT FROM
CSU SACRAMENTO THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GLAZERS WE WILL NOW GO
TO LEAD SUPPORT. IF MADAME
MODERATOR OF HEAP TRAN IS ON
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS AND ELLA
COMMITTEE. I CALLED TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN
EIGHT FIVE. I'M CURRENTLY A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY GRADUATING WITH A BA
IN HISTORY. I'LL BE GRADUATING
THIS MAY. I AM ONE OF THOSE
LUCKY. UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS WHO BE ABLE TO STATE I
GRADUATED WITHIN FOUR YEARS I
COULD NOT HAVE DONE THIS UP THE
HELP OF THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDED ME WITH
THE PANTS DEVISING AND PRIORITY
REGISTRATION. THE FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THE PROGRAM AFTER
RECEIVING A LETTER FROM SOCCER
STATE UNIVERSITY STATING I WAS
CALLED BY THE JOINT CAL
PROMISED. SOMEONE WHO TOOK THE
CAL PROMISE PLEDGE MY FIRST
SEMESTER BACK IN FALL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- SENTENCING
DIFFICULTY. NAVIGATING COLLEGE
LIFE. LIKE MANY CALL STUDENTS
ALSO ME WORKING A FULL TIME JOB
ADDITION TO BEING A FULL TIME
STUDENT. HAVING AN ADVISER
HELPED GUIDE ME THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROGRAM WAS
CRUCIAL IN GETTING ME TO WHERE
I AM TODAY WELL NOW WE
GRADUATING WITH THE SAME COLOR.
MY FRESHMAN YEAR. I RECALL
AFTER HAVING ONE OF MY BUSIEST
MOST DIFFICULT MONSTERS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BUT MY GENERAL
VISOR RECOMMENDED TO LIKE
THERE'S SOMETHING ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS BUT
DRASTICALLY REDUCE MY WORKLOAD.
I WAS JUST LAST FALL THEY SPOKE
TO GRADUATION VISOR. WHEN FOR
DEEP INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
THE PARTY COURSE CREDIT. SO I
COULD MAKE THOSE MEANINGFUL
CONNECTIONS. GAIN WORK
EXPERIENCE RELATIVE MY CAREER
GOALS AND STILL GRADUATE WITHIN
FOUR YEARS. AND IT'S NOT JUST
ADVISING CAL PROMISED RIDES.
ALSO GIVEN EXTENSIVE DEGREE
ROADMAP TO KEEP ME ON TRACK AND
ORGANIZE. IT PROVIDED ITS
PRIORITY REGISTRATION. A
NECESSITY TO NUMBER AND TACTIC
COURSES OFFERED. CAL PROMISE
PROGRAMS SAVE ME FROM TAKING
ADDITIONAL SEMESTERS TO GET MY
DEGREE. GOING INTO FINANCIAL
DEBT. THE HARSH REALITIES THAT
MANY STUDENTS ARE UNAWARE OF
THIS PROGRAM EVEN EXISTS ON
CAMPUSES. THE LACK OF OUTREACH
AND ACCESSIBILITY HAS MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SUCH AN IMPACTFUL
PROGRAM. FOR STUDENTS SHOULD BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM. I
ASK YOU ALL HERE TODAY TO VOTE
I ON SB SEVEN EIGHT FIVE IN
ORDER TO HELP MORESTUDENTS
LIKE ME SUCCEED IN THEIR
COLLEGE CAREERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SHOWING
NO OTHER LEAD US SUPPORT SO WE
WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE FOR SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THING NO ONE WILL GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE FINE MADAM HAD
READER CAN YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SKEWS ME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. CONTRACT THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
TAKE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN
NOW. AT THIS TIME AND I'M SURE
WE HAVE ONE PERSON Q. THANK YOU.
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNIG THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
MODERATOR I AM SHOWING THAT I
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE FOR OPPOSITION OF SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SEEING THEN
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE MATAMATA
RATED TO HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF SEVENTY FIVE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THAT'S ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW. AT
THE TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENT SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANKS GLACIER- WERE I KNOW
HE'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS-
PROGRAM FOR A VERY LONG TIME I
APPRECIATE THINKING THE CHARGE
ADMITTING. BY CAMPUS- OF A SEC
MISSTATED IS ACTUALLY A LEADER
AND- IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM.
I KNOW THAT PART OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS IN THE PAST HAS
ALSO BEEN ABOUT- AND ENSURING
THAT WE DON'T DISADVANTAGED.
STUDENTS MAKE COME FROM LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES ARE ON
REPRESENTS COMMUNITIES WHERE.
IN A PROJECT THAT THE WITNESS-
TALK ABOUT HIM TRY JUNGLE JOB
WITH HIS- WORKING CAMPUS AND-
STILL BE ABLE TO KEEP THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISED BECAUSE IS
WORKING PRIORITIES THOSE GROUPS
I DO APPRECIATE THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THAT. SELLS
REQUIREMENTS 70% OF THE
PARTICIPANTS BE FROM. THE A BC
STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW INCOME
FIRST GENERATION IT'S AND FROM
UNDER ITS COMMUNITY. AND SUCH
EASY ADDRESSING THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE IN THIS BILL AND-
CERTAINLY- PLEASE SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WOULD MOVE IT AT THE
PROPER TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CENTER PANCER CORTESE.
TAKING IF I CAN A CENTER JUST
ACROSS ON. THE FISCAL SIDE OF
IT SO TO SPEAK- IN THE BY THE
WAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO YOUR
STAFF YOUR OFFICE FOR. FREE
ANSWERING SOME QUESTIONS FOR US
SO TO GET CLEAR ON THIS IT.
HELPED A LOT AND PROBABLY SAVE
SOMETIME TODAY- THE QUESTION I
HAVE A LIKE- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO THE DOCTOR CAN I
HELP- IT IN I KNOW YOU'RE QUITE
AWARE THIS- SOUNDS A STATE
UNIVERSITY IS. IS ONE OF THE-
BIG CHAMPIONS OF WHAT THEY CALL
SPARTAN PROMISE- THIS PROGRAM
BASICALLY. IT'S AUGMENTED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY. WHAT HAS BEEN
AT LEAST UP TO MILITARY WEALTHY
COUNTIES COUNTY SANTA CLARA YOU
KNOW REALLY PROVIDING THEM.
GRANTS YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE
MID TO HIGH SIX FIGURE LEVEL-
JUST SOUTH OF A MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR AT TIMES TO ESSENTIALLY
PAY FOR. THE SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE STUDENTS TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SUCCESSFUL IN THE PROGRAM- BEEN
IN IT SEEMS TO WORK- MY CONCERN
IN IT THE SALUTE BILL ALONG THE
LINES OF. THE EQUITY ISSUE AS
WELL AS- FOR ONE THING LET ME
JUST PUT A- BIG HUGE TAKE THE
PRESSURE OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WITH THE FISCAL SITUATION
THEY'RE IN RIGHT NOW I'M NOT
SURE THEY CAN CONTINUE DOING
THAT- BUT WHAT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
AREAS. IN THE STATE WERE THAT
KIND OF ASSISTANCE MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE I. AM JUST ONE WHAT.
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF. LOW BUDGET
WASTE TO PROMOTE THE PROGRAM TO
PROMOTE ENROLLMENT IN THE
PROGRAM- BUT- THIS THIS IDEA OF.
HELLO OF THE MENTORS AND THE
KIND OF ASSISTANCE THAT THAT
REALLY. MAKES PEOPLE STEP IN
THE PROGRAM. IS IT SOMETHING
AND AGAIN I IN KNOWLEDGE EVEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A LONG TIME
IT LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF THIS
WOULDN'T HAVE EXISTED WITHOUT
YOUR EFFORTS SO JUST WONDER
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT
BEFORE WE MOVE ON. THANK YOU
SENATOR- LET ME JUST SAY THAT
SAN JOSE STATE- ALONG WITH
SACRAMENTO STATE ARE THE TWO
LEADERS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADVANCE IN THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION PROGRAM WE REFER TO
AS THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE IN.
SACRAMENTO I THINK IT'S
FINISHING FOR. SPARTAN PRODUCTS
I MEAN EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT
NAME FOR IT BUT THAT. THE POINT
OF IT IS TO LET STUDENTS KNOW.
THAT THEY CAN GET THROUGH IN
FOUR YEARS AND THE UNIVERSE IS
THERE TO HELP THEM- SENATOR YOU
KNOW THAT- FIVE YEARS AGO AT
SAN JOSE STATE THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE WAS ELEVEN
PERCENT. ELEVEN PERCENT- AT THE
TIME THE SYSTEM WIDE GRADUATION
RATE IN FOUR YEARS WAS 19%
TODAY THAT RATE IS OVER TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. IT'S MORE THAN
DOUBLED IN FOUR YEARS THROUGH
THE GREAT LEADERSHIP AT YOUR
CAMPUS THERE. AND THE AND THE
FACULTY IN THE UNIVERSITY. THE
STATE ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO FIVE
YEARS AGO STARTED PROVIDING
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT FOR. THE
CALPERS PROGRAM FOR THE
GRADUATION FOR EFFORTS AND WE
HAVE THROUGH OUR BUDGET HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR
SPECIFICALLY TO HELP CAMPUSES
LIKE YOURS AND OTHERS. TO
PROMOTE THE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
THAT ENHANCE ADVISING. BUDGET
TO MAKE IT WORK AND I HOPE THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE THAT
COMMITMENT. TO OUR BUDGET
PROCESS I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS ONCE AGAIN
STEPPED UP AND SAID I WANT TO
FUND THESE PROGRAMS AND HE HAS
PUT IN I THINK- THIS TWENTY
MILLION BUT IT'S A SIZABLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY I THINK. WE'D
LIKE IT TO BE MORE- AND- THE
CHALLENGE IN THE REASON THIS
BILL IT'S BEEN PUT BEFORE USE
THAT THE SYSTEMS DO A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS AND YOUR- TWO
CAMPUSES IN PARTICULAR DOING
EXTRAORDINARY WORK. BUT FOR
MANY CAMPUSES THEY'RE NOT. AND
THE ENROLLMENT IN THE IN THE
PHOENICIAN FOR CAL POLICIES
INCREDIBLY LOW- AND SO THIS IS
A BILL TO NUDGE THEM TO DO A
LITTLE BIT BETTER TO IMPROVE
THAT. ENROLLMENT BY 5% EACH
YEAR. AND THEY CAN DO IT
THROUGH ADVERTISING THROUGH- IT
YOU KNOW AND IN SOME OF THE
UNIVERSITIES TAKE SEVEN CLICKS
TO FIND THE CAL PROMISE PROGRAM
ON THEIR WEBSITE. NOT ONE OR
TWO BUT BUT SEVEN. BOB
PROMOTING IT DURING ORIENTATION
HAS A LOT TO THE INEXPENSIVE
WAYS JUST LET STUDENTS NOW. IF
THEY KNEW THEY COULD GET
THROUGH IN FOUR YEARS. THE
ENROLLMENT. IN THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY GREATER.
AND FIND DEFECT DOES TO SAID
PAN POINTS. THE FOLKS OF THE
PROGRAM FROM THE BEGINNING WAS
UNDER REPRESENTED. AND I'M
PLEASED TO SAY THAT AFTER THREE
FULL YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION WE
SEE THAT IS EXACTLY WHO IS
BEING SERVED. AND SO THIS BILL
SIMPLY CONTINUES THE GREAT
EFFORT BY THE UNIVERSITY TO
ADVANCE THAT I HOPE I'VE
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. YOU
KNOW THEIR NO IT'S REASSURING
AND SUPPORTIVE SO IN A CAME IN
SUPPORT OF BUT IT JUST WANTED
TO HEAR THAT REASSURANCE IN
TERMS OF CONTINUING. THIS IS A
FIGHT AT THIS LEVEL FOR
WHATEVER NECESSARY FUNDING
THERE IS TO MAKE SURE WE
AREN'T. IT AT SOME POINT. SORT
OF CREATE A PROGRAM AND THEN.
UNINTENTIONAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES HAVING KIDS OUT TO
DRY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T. A
LITTLE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN MINDFUL
THAT PLEASE SEND YOUR COMMENTS-
I ALSO IF I MAY UM. BUT IN A
GET INTO THE WEB. SO THAT THAT
SOME. WE JUST HARD THAN IT IS
FOR PEOPLE TO GET TO THE- TO
LOCATE HOW TO GET A SENIOR TAX
EXEMPTION- BOUNCING AROUND FROM
WEBSITE TO WEBSITE- JUST TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES THE STATE A
LITTLE BITON THE GRIP FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATE THEY BASICALLY
MOVED TO A FIVE YEAR. A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE PROGRAM THERE
BECAUSE BECAUSE UNIVERSITY
ITSELF IS SO OVER SAID
SUBSCRIBE SO IMPACTED THAT IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO
GET UP THE CLASSES THE NEED
OVER A FOUR YEAR PROGRAM SO I
JUST I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FIVE
YOUR NUMBERS LOOK LIKE- AND I
CERTAINLY NOT SUGGESTING THIS
PROGRAM SHOULD BE A FIVE YEAR
PROGRAM I JUST WANTED TO SAY-
THAT- I KNOW THEY HAVE OTHER
ISSUES HERE THAT ARE.
CONSTRAINING THEIR ABILITY TO.
A TO GET STUDENTS IN AND OUT
OVER FOUR YEAR CYCLE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VENTURE. THANK CENTER
CORTESE ANY OTHER QUESTION YES
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU I ALSO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
SENATOR I VOTED ON YOUR LAST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN AWESOME SO I
JUST WANNA SAY. THAT SOMEBODY
WHO DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE- QUITE
FRANKLY BECAUSE I COULDN'T AND
THE REASON WE COULDN'T I
COULDN'T GO WAS BECAUSE WE WERE
FARMERS WE HAD LAND BUT NO
MONEY. AND SO WE DISCUSS IT
DISQUALIFIED ME FOR ANY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR ANY OF
THOSE TYPE OF PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THE SYSTEM DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
YOUR CASH IT RECOGNIZED YOUR-
ASSETS. SO WITH THAT BEING SAID
I HAVE THREE CHILDREN AND I
HAVE AND MY WIFE AND I HAVE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY TO MAKE
SURE THEY GO TO. A COLLEGE AND
FROM DAY ONE WE TOLD HIM
THEY'RE GONNA GO BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE VALUE OF THAT. AND SO
AT THIS POINT I HAVE TWO SONS
ATTENDING CAL POLY SAN LUIS.
AND IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND IT
ALSO IS VERY IMPACTED SO I WISH
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE ARMY THIS IS
THE QUESTION- THE PROBLEM WITH
GETTING OUT IN FOUR YEARS YOU
CAN'T GET SOME OF THOSE CLASSES
YOU HAVE TO HAVE BECAUSE ARE
IMPACTED. WHICH MEANS THAT
THERE'S NO MORE ROOM IN THE
CLASS SO WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION DISADVANTAGED THOSE
KIDS THAT ARE IN THIS PROGRAM
AND BUMP THEM OUT AND THEN
THOSE IMPACTED CLASSES WILL
STILL BE IMPACTED AND THEY
WON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY GET
THAT. THE CLASSES THEY NEED TO
GET THEIR DEGREE. SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
ADVANTAGE IN SOMEBODY TO TRY TO
GET OUT FOR YEARS THE COST OF
DISADVANTAGES SOMEBODY ELSE AND
I'LL JUST. SAY THAT THE BIGGEST
CALL I MEAN WE JUST HAD THE
LAST BILL TALK ABOUT COST. COST
IS THE COST OF LIVING I MEAN
THE- RENT AND- ALL THOSE THINGS
LIVING AWAIT ME KNOW YOU'RE
BASICALLY SUPPLYING AND A
SECOND HOUSEHOLD. FOR YOUR
STUDENT- WHEN THEIR COLLEGE SO
THOSE ARE THE COSTS THAT
REALLY- WHO ARE. OKAY PACKING
US AS WELL SO I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF GET A FLAVOR I DON'T.
REALLY HAVE I NOT MADE MY MIND
UP ON THIS BILL BECAUSE I WANT
TO THAT'S ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT. I WOULD LOVE FOR MY- SONS
TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT IN FOUR
YEARS BECAUSE IT'S A HECK OF A
SAVINGS TO NOT HAVE. YOU KNOW
EACH ONE OF THEM TWO EXTRA
YEARS TO GET OUT. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY- LET ME ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION ON IMPACTION THIS
WAY- FIRST THE MAKE KNOWLEDGE
THE POINT YOU JUST MADE WHICH
IS THE- THE COST TO THE-
STUDENT AND THEIR FAMILIES IS
THE COST OF LIVING- AND THAT
WHEN YOU GO FROM A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE TO A FIVE OR SIX YEAR
DEGREE. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN THOSE
COSTS- AND EFFECT FOR MANY.
STUDENTS TODAY. IN FACT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
IN CALIFORNIA. ARE INCURRING
THAT DEBT. AND THEY'RE NEVER
GETTING A DEGREE. THINK ABOUT
THAT TRAGEDY YOU KNOW SPENT A
LOT OF THE TIME BUT- THE FOCUS
OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- DEAL WITH THAT. THAT
THEY CAN GET THEIR PROGRESS
TOWARDS A DEGREE HERE'S AN
INTERESTING FACTOID. ABOUT 90%
OF THE STUDENTS. AT THE CSU.
THAT SAN LUIS OBISPO AND ALL
THE OTHER TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES. THEY'RE TAKING A FULL
LOAD RIGHT NOW. BUT THEY CAN'T
THE CLASSES NECESSARILY. LEAN
TOWARDS THAT DEGREE WHY IS THAT.
SOME CASES IT'S IMPACTION BUT
IMPACTION COMES BECAUSE THE
CLASSES THAT THERE'S A
COMPACTION IS WITHIN THE DEGREE
PROGRAM AND THEN THERE'S
ABILITY TO GET A CLASS SO
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
I THINK YOU BROUGHT THEM
TOGETHER. BUT THE ABILITY TO
GET A CLASS IS A CENTRAL ISSUE
THAT THE THESE CAMPUSES HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH. AND WHETHER
IT'S A PRE REQUISITE THAT ONE
HAS TO TAKE IN A CERTAIN ORDER
TO GET TO A DEGREE WHICH I
THINK IS A SPEND SOME OF THE
DEGREE PROGRAMS THAT SALAS
OBISPO MUCH MORE CUTE. THE
CAMPUSES OF GOT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT DEMAND AND MEET IT. AND IF
YOU'RE OFFERING COURSES- AND-
YOU KNOW- INTERNATIONAL ART.
HISTORY AND NO ONE'S TAKING IT
AND THEN YEAR COURSE IN
ARCHITECTURE EVERYBODY'S TAKING
IT YOU KIND OF STARTED JESTING.
BUT TO MEET THAT DEMAND AND FOR
MANY THE CAMPUSES THAT'S BEEN A
STRUGGLE. THAT'S BEEN OF THAT'S
BEEN A BIG BARRIER IS THE
ABILITY TO SHIFT THE COURSES
OFFERED TO WHAT STUDENTS WANT
SO AS I TALKED AT THE BEGINNING
THAT MOST STUDENTS ARE TAKING A
FULL LOAD WIRES TO GET AT
FIFTEEN UNITS A SEMESTER. SO
WHY ARE THEY GETTING THROUGH
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT TAKING THE
RIGHT COURSES BECAUSE THE
COURSES THEY NEED ARE NOT
AVAILABLE. AND SO THE PURPOSE
OF THESE PROGRAMS LIKE CAL
PROMISE IS TO PROVIDE THAT
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT URGE THAT
PUSH TO MAKE CAMPUSES BE MORE
RESPONSIVE. AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGE AND WHY THIS BILL
THIS YEAR THAT THAT THEY'RE NOT
ADVERTISING IT IS THE KIDS ARE
GOING TO PUT THE MAN ON THEM TO
MAKE THOSE COURSES AVAILABLE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO NOT HAVE TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO SO KIDS CAN GET
THOSE COURSES AND GET THROUGH
LIKE YOUR SONS. AND SO IT'S ALL
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO ENCOURAGE THE CAMPUS TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE AND TO GIVE THE
KIDS THAT FOR YOUR TRACK THAT
WILL SAY THAN A HECK OF A LOT
OF MONEY AND GET THEM TO
DEGREE. WHICH. PROVIDES
ENORMOUS LIFETIME VALUE. BUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
CLARIFICATION AT SO WILL THE-
WILL IT. BOB OTHER OTHER
STUDENTS THAT ARE PROBABLY
TAKING A FULL LOAD OUT BECAUSE
WE'RE GOOD WE'RE DEBATE WHERE
SOMEBODY ACTUALLY SIGNS UP IN
THIS PROGRAM THAT'S- KIND OF
WHAT I WANTED TO GET AN ANSWER
FOR. I DON'T BELIEVE IT WILL.
IF YOU HAVE A CAMPUS IT'S BEING
RESPONSIVE TO STUDENT DEMAND.
WHICH IS IN MANY CASES IN SOME
CASES NOT HAPPENING TODAY. I
THINK IT'S GOING TO MAKE MORE
COURSE OFFERINGS OPENED UP FOR
THE KIDS THAT WANT TO GET IT
AND CAN'T IN ORDER TO STAY ON
THAT TRACK I DON'T THINK IT'S
GONNA- IT'S GOING TO ME THE
OTHER STUDENTS I MEAN I THINK
IF YOU SEE A LOOK AT LOOK AT
THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE
FOUR YEARS AGO THE- FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE AT CSU WAS
NINETEEN PERCENT. AND TODAY
IT'S THIRTY AND I'VE SET A GOAL
OF BRINGING IT 240% BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. EVERYTHING IS
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
MORE KIDS ARE GETTING THEIR
COURSES AND MORE KIDS ARE
GRADUATING. AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE SUCCESS
OF THE LAST FOUR YEARS THAT THE
PROVEN SUCCESS. MORE KIDS ARE
GETTING THROUGH SO I THINK.
THAT IRAQ'S AT ISRAEL IS FAIR
ENOUGH. BUT I THINK THAT THE
OVERALL IT'S MAKING ENORMOUS
PROGRESS FOR OUR A BROADER
STUDENT BODY AND I THINK YOUR-
CHILDREN ALL. OF OUR CHILDREN.
WILL BENEFIT FROM THAT. WELL
I'M IN A THE MIDST OF FOR YOUR
BILL I THINK YOU MAKE A- ARGUE.
I WOULD SAY- AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
JUST. LETTING THIS RIGHT NOW
ACTUALLY WITH MY SONS. AS THE
QUESTIONS YOU DON'T ASK THAT
DON'T GET ANSWERED I MEAN WE
WENT TO THE- ORIENTATION FOR.
OUR OLDEST SON. A FEW YEARS
BACK HE'S A JUNIOR. CAL POLY
AND IS WAS LIKE THE YOU KNOW
THEY SAY THAT IT'S A GREAT
COMMUNITY OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY
LOVES ST LOUIS IT'S- YOU KNOW
CLOSE THE OCEAN IS BEAUTIFUL
AND- HE SAID YOU A LOT OF OUR
KIDS. ARE FIVE YEARS AND SO
THAT SPURRED THE THOUGHT TO ME
OF THE CALL I'M THINKING ABOUT
THE COST MY SON'S THINKING
ABOUT A- FIVE YEAR SOUNDS GREAT
AS LONG AS HE'S NOT PAYING FOR
BUT HE IS PAINFUL FOR EXCEL.
THE WHY IS THAT DEALT WITH THE
QUESTION IS WHY IS IT FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET.
NOW REALIZING HE'S A JUNIOR AND
HE NEEDS TO TAKE HE'S GOING TO
BE IT. IS TAKING CROPSCIENCE
AND HE HAS TO DO LABS I MEAN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO WHICH IS REALLY
DIFFICULT NOW WITH. ZOOMING YOU
DON'T DO LABS VERY WELL IT WHEN
YOU'RE- ZOOMING. OR IMPACT YOU
JUST DON'T DON'T. AND SO WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE THAT ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES
WITH AT FIVE YEARS WHICH IS
AND- ANOTHER YEAR OF. YOU KNOW
UP. TO TWELVE DOLLARS A MONTH
FOR JUST RENT- SO. ALL SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY I'M GONNA WATCH
AS I'M- I WANT TO BE HELPFUL I
THINK THIS IS A- ON THE RIGHT.
YOUR TRACK RECORD WITH THE LAST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
AWESOME. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT. ADVANTAGE IN SOME
OVER OTHERS AND- BECAUSE ARE
ALL FACED WITH THE IMPACT
PROBLEM THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT AND I THINK WE NEED TO. PUSH
ON OUR- ON THE EDUCATION OF THE
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS TO. MAKE SURE
THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB CAN
CANCELING THESE KIDS AND MAKING
SURE THEY GET THE RIGHT CLASSES
SO THEY CAN. GET OUT IN FOUR
YEARS SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT BEFORE I ASK YOU TO CLOSE
UNDER GLAZER I WOULD JUST SAY.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE BEEN HERE
LONG ENOUGH TO SEE THIS WORK
THAT YOU DO WORK YOU'RE DOING.
ACTUALLY OF THE FRUITFUL AND BE
HELPING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING THAT
WORK. AND SENATOR DOLLY I WOULD
SAY I WOULD CAL POLY POMONA AND
MY PARENTS WERE THOSE PARENTS
WHO MADE ENOUGH TO NOT BUT I
COULDN'T QUALIFY FOR ANYTHING
BUT THEY ALSO COULDN'T AFFORD
TO SEND ME TO GIVE ME ANY MONEY
FOR COLLEGE. BUT I HAD A GOOD
UNION JOBS IF I WAS ABLE TO PUT
MYSELF THROUGH COLLEGE. AND IT
WAS ALSO A LOT CHEAPER WHEN OUR
GIRLS WENT TO SCHOOL WE TOLD
THAT WE WILL PAY BUT IF YOU
DON'T FINISH IN FOUR YEARS THE
REST IS ON YOU. SO THOSE LITTLE
GIRLY FINISHED IN FOUR YEARS
AND IT WAS ON US. BUT WHICH IS
FINE SENATOR GLAZERS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GOOD WORK PLEASE
CLOSE. THANK YOU CHARLIE OF I
WANT TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE
NOT JUST FOR TODAY'S
CONSIDERATION BUT FOR THE-
COOPERATION SUPPORT THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN ME OVER THE YEARS TO
ADVANCE THIS PROGRAM YOU KNOW I
CAME TO THE SENATE- AS A- BEING
A TRUSTEE OF THE STATE
UNIVERSITY FOR FOUR YEARS
BEFORE I WAS ELECTED TO THE
SENATE. AND I GOT TO SEE THIS
INCREDIBLE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM UP
CLOSE. AND WHAT THEY DO WANT
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY AND
QUALITY IS BAR NONE THE BEST IN
A IN A IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT THIS FOCUS ON STUDENT
SUCCESS NOT JUST GETTING
STUDENTS ENGAGEMENT THROUGH IT.
WAS IT WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY
DIDN'T GET A LOT OF ATTENTION.
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT
WHEN I GET DEEPER INTO THE
ISSUE I'VE LEARNED THAT AT
POMONA AND SAN BERNARDINO. THEY
WERE THE TWO CAMPUSES THAT WERE
EXPERIMENTING WITH THIS TEN
YEARS AGO. AND NOBODY REALLY
KNEW ABOUT THEIR WORK IN THE
WORK OF THE GREAT LEADERSHIP ON
THOSE TWO CAMPUSES AND IT WAS
MY LEARNING OF THEIR- THEIR
PILOT PROGRAMS AND THE SUCCESS
THEY WERE HAVING THAT.
MOTIVATED ME TO ADVANCE THIS ON
A SYSTEM WIDE BASIS AS A
TRUSTEE AND HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IS HAVING
EXTRAORDINARY RESULTS NOT FROM
MY WORK BUT FOR THE GREAT
FACULTY AND UNIVERSITY LEADERS
THAT WE HAVE. AND THIS BILL IS
GOING TO THE GYM A LITTLE BIT
THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO. TOO
LITTLE OVERSIGHT AND TO
ENCOURAGE AND TRY. TO MAKE THEM
BE BETTER- AND I TO THAT THAT.
THEY WILL HAVE THAT READ. IN I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR- TODAY.
BIG CENTER. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SAID PAM MAN FOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
NUMBER TWO. SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA AYE.
LEYVA AYE OTOBO. AYE THE
TROUBLED BY CORTESE ALL RIGHT.
COURTESY I DALY AYE. DALY YE
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAN
HI. AND I THAT BILLS OUT SIX
ZERO. WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
SB FIFTY. SENATOR LEE MON IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTING THERE
SHE IS. GOOD MORNING SENATOR-
SHE'S ARE USING S. B. FIFTY
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND- SB FIFTY
MAKES- AND CHANGE IT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM PARTICULARLY BY
OPENING MORE OPTIONS FOR
INFANTS TODDLERS. I PERSONALLY
KNOW HOW CHALLENGING IT IS TO
LOOK FOR CHILD CARE OPTIONS
WITH AN INFANT MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS BASICALLY THE SAME
STRUGGLES. CURRENTLY OUR SYSTEM
IS ONLY SERVING 10% OF ELIGIBLE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR INFANT
AND TODDLER CARE AND S. B. HE
WILL MAKE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
INEFFICIENCY IN THE SYSTEM SO
THAT IT CAN BETTER SERVE
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY CHANGES BUT ALLOWS
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY FIRST
THIS BILL WILL OPEN AT THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE.
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
WE HAVE MADE SEVERAL
INVESTMENTS TO STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM BUT HAVE NOT MADE THE
SAME TYPES OF INVESTMENTS FOR
INSTANCE IN TODDLERS. BY
OPENING A STATE PROGRAM TO MORE
AGES BEING ANSWERED MORE
UNDERSERVED INFANTS TODDLERS
AND ALLOW FOR WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN'S NGK.
AND INTEGRATE. THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR PROVIDE TO TRY THE STATE
PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CONT. EVEN
PROVIDERS MARK. TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN DO NOT
LOSE CARE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
ENABLE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS JUST YOUNG CHILDREN
IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
FINALLY THIS BILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO ENROLL
IN STEAM ROLLED IN CHILD CARE
IT EASES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON PARENTS TO PROVIDERS
BY ESTABLISHING TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS OF CONTINUOUS LEGIBILITY
AND ALLOWING FOR CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY. I AM COMMITTED TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
REFINE THIS BILL AS THE BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME E. R. E.
BAGHEL APPARENT FROM SAN JOSE
AND LISA LOOK AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FROM THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CONSORTIUM OF LOS
ANGELES IT'S IMPORTANT THE BILL
AND ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU CENTER
AMOUNT WILL GO TO YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES ARE. MS HELLO IF
YOU'RE READY PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING- SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO SHARE MY
STORY WITH YOU MY NAME IS
GETTING OUT OF ALL I WAS BORN
IN MEXICO AND REYES. FAMILY
EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF MY LIFE I
WILL BRING A MOTHER OF A THREE
YEAR OLD BOY FINDING AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE CENTER HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR THE PAST YEAR
UNTIL I FOUND FAITH IN THE
CHILD CARE CENTER. IN NOVEMBER
OF TWO THOUSAND ONE. FROM MY
THIRDS. I HAD TO FINDING
SOMETHING THAT I COULD AFFORD.
TO TAKE A VERY LONG TIME TO
FIND A PROGRAM THAT MET MY
NEEDS THAT THE WORKING MOM.
WHEN I RETURNED FROM MATERNITY
LEAVE I HAD NO OTHER CHOICE
THAN TO FIND A BABYSITTER ON MY
OWN. SHE CARE FOR MY SON FOR MY
INTERNSHIP COULD NO LONGER
WATCH. I HAD A WEEKEND TO
FIGURE OUT WHO I WAS GOING TO
LEAVE MY BABY WITH SO THAT I
COULD SHOW UP TO WORK ON
MONDAY. I WATCH FOR THE
HELPLESS SITUATION I FOUND
MYSELF AND- I WENT FROM
BABYSITTER THE BABYSITTER. THAT
IS NOT WHAT I WANTED FOR MY SON.
IF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENROLL MY CHILD AS AN INFANT
TODDLER. I WOULD FEEL HAPPY
KNOWING THAT MY SON WOULD BE
TAKING CARE OF ATTY THE
QUALITY. BUT HE WAS ALSO
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT. SKILL
BE CONSERVANCY OF TAKING HIM TO
A CHILD CARE CENTER WHERE I
KNOW HE WOULD BE LOVED. TALKING
CARE BOARD. WOULD RELIEVE ME
FROM MUCH UNNECESSARY STRESS.
LET ALONE HELPING. AND VALUABLE
THAN EDUCATE EXPERIENCE. THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN FOR MY SON AT
THE GYM EARLY AGE. AND WHAT
THEY WOULD DO FOR HIS ACADEMIC
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE. WHY
EXPANSION OF INFANT CHILD CARE
CENTERS IN VERY MUCH NEED IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I AM A TEACHER
BUT MY EARNINGS ARE SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH TO COVER THE COST OF
CHILDCARE AND DELAPORTE LIVE IN
ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE. IN
CALIFORNIA. I MAKING ENDS MEET
WITH WHAT I CAN'T. I KNOW THAT
MANY OTHER PARENTS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE TROUBLE FINDING
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CHILDCARE.
PENSION THE INFANTILE CARE.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY STORY. THAT'S WHY I
SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT IT UP WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS WILL
CAN ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM.
PLEASE PROCEED THE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. FINALLY TO WALK AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CONSORTIUM OF LOS
ANGELES OR CDC LA. WHERE A
TITLE SCIENCE CENTER BASED
DIRECT CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY. P. FIFTY PROVIDE
PROPOSES TO MAKE CHANGES TO THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THAT WILL
CREATE EFFICIENCIES FOR BOTH
THE FAMILIES AND THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAM TO SEARCH THEM. ONE
SUCH EFFICIENCY IS THE ABILITY
FOR FAMILIES TO BE
CATEGORICALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM SERVICES. IF THEY HAVE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED ELIGIBILITY
FOR ANOTHER MEANS TESTED
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
MEDICARE OR CALFRESH. CURRENTLY
FAMILIES HAVE TO PROVE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITH EACH PROGRAM HAVING TO
CERTIFY THE FAMILY SEPARATELY.
THIS IS A WASTE OF TIME FOR THE
FAMILY TO MAY HAVE TO GATHER
NEW DOCUMENTATION EACH TIME.
WAIT WHILE EACH PROGRAM WORKS
TO CONFIRM THAT THE
DOCUMENTATION IS VALID. ONCE
BILL BECOMES LAW A FAMILY WOULD
BE ABLE TO BE CERTIFIED ONE
TIME IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR MULTIPLE PROGRAMS INCLUDING
STATE PRESCHOOL. AND THEN TAKE
PROOF OF THAT CERTIFICATION TO
ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR. CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO
USE THAT CERTIFICATION IS PROOF
OF ELIGIBILITY SAVING HOURS OF.
CLERICAL WORK AND
ADMINISTRATIVE TIME. SHOULD BE
WOULD ALLOW CHARTER PROGRAMS
THE ABILITY TO BURN OUR
CONTRACT BASED ON CHILD
ENROLLMENT NOT ATTENDANCE.
CURRENTLY UCLA PROGRAM STAFF
SPEND OUT COUNTLESS HOURS
TRACKING ATTENDANCE AND
ABSENCES. EACH ABSENCE MUST BE
ACCOUNTED FOR BASED ON THE
REASON FOR THE ABSENCE. AND
FAMILIES MAY LOSE CARE IF THEIR
CHILD IS ABSENT FOR THE WRONG
REASON TOO MANY TIMES. WHEN
EXCUSE DOESN'T THAT ARE
GENERALLY NOT REIMBURSABLE
LEAVING THE CONTRACT TURNING
OUT OF THE CONTROL OF THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAM. OPERABLE TO FIND
ANOTHER CHILD TO FILL THE EMPTY
SPACE LEFT BY A PERIODICALLY
ABSENT CHILD AND PROGRAMS ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO ENROLL EXTRA
CHILDREN. CAN MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE OF LICENSING
REGULATIONS. REIMBURSEMENT
BASED ON ENROLLMENT WHAT ALLOW
PROGRAMS A MORE STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE BASE EARNINGS
GIVING US MORE TIME TO SUPPORT
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
OUR PROGRAM. EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS IS ANOTHER WAY TO
STREAMLINE THE CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS AND BETTER ENSURE THAT
CHILD DEVELOPMENT FUNDS ARE NOT
RETURNED TO THE STATE. FAMILIES
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HAVING ALL
OF THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN SERVED
UNDER THE SAME CONTRACT INSTEAD
OF HAVING THEIR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS COULD ROBERT PLEASE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. AND THEN
GO HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
SEPARATE CERTIFICATION PROCESS
FOR THEIR PRESCHOOLERS. WITH
TWO SEPARATE CONTRACTS
UNDERTAKEN SEPARATELY THE
LAPTOP YOU WELL OVER THE LINE.
AS A CHILD CARE THAT WATER
WOULD AGE OUT OF THE PROGRAM.
I'VE HIGHLIGHTED JUST A FEW OF
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT SB FIFTY
WOULD MAKE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THERE
ARE MORE YOUR SUPPORT WOULD
PROVIDE BENEFITS TO BOTH THE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
AND THE FAMILIES THEY SERVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE FOR SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE
HERE WILL LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE THERE WE
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
FIND META MODERATED WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY CONFERENCE ONE ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER INFLATION
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
THEIR OWN NOW. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NINE PEOPLE AND
YOU. VERY GOOD PRE PLEASE
PROCEED. NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MOMENT LINE NUMBER TWENTY
TWO. FORMER MANAGER. GIVE ME A
MOMENT I'M SURE LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE HAVING AN ISSUE WITH THE
ALARM ONE MOMENT. ONE MOMENT.
MY NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK THAT THE OPEN ONE MOMENT
DURING THE RESULT LINE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO YOU CAN YOU CAN
SPEAK YOUR MIND IS OPEN. GO
AHEAD MOVE TO THE NEXT LINE
ALONG AND WE CAN COME BACK AND
OUTLINED DIGITAL JUST. ONE
MOMENT. WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES LIMóN MADAM CHAIR
NO PROBLEM. IT WITHIN ONE
SECOND I'M SURE ONE MOMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU UNTIL WE'RE
GOING TO TRY THIS AGAIN ONE
MOMENT. MY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS DONNA
HOFFMAN CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
COUNCIL BIRTH TRONG AMERICA
READY NATION FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS AND MISSION
READINESS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS REPORTING US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OUT
ADELINE. ST IN SUPPORT YEAH
THANK YOU. NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
SENATORS MY NAME INTENSELY
DEVARAJAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN AND
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MICHELLE SILVERMAN'S HE OF
KATANGA EARLY LEARNING
NONPROFIT PROUD TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MRS KELLY
REYNOLDS ON BEHALF OF EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIA COASTLINE THIRD
SB FIFTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS MY NUMBER PERFECT WELL
I AM A PARENT AND MEMBER OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL
AND I AM OF BOTH REPORT EVENT
THE FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KEN
HERRON- I'M ACROSS PRIVATE
PROVIDER IN FRESNO COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IT
SEEMS LIKE A NO BRAINER YOU
MAKE IT A LOT MORE EFFICIENT.
TEMPERATURE GRAYSON- IT SEEMS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE A
SERVING A YOUNGER YOUNGER
CHILDREN SEEMS TO BE WHAT
SACRAMENTO'S WANTING SO IN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
ALSO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
RATE INCREASE. FOR ALL THESE
CENTRAL BROWN WORKERS MOSTLY
WOMEN JUST A MOMENT PLEASE SIR
LAST YEAR. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MY NUMBER MY
NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT RIGHT
FIRE- MY NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YEAH WE COLLECT
THAT THERE. MY NUMBER FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ROBIN
MCCONNELL WITHTHE FAMILY YMCA
OF THE DESERT WE RUN COMMUNITY
BASED CHILD CARE CENTER SERVING
ZERO TO FIVE IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM. HERE ON BEHALF OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT AND SB
FIFTY THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE OF TURN UP AT
THE MOMENT MANAGER ONE MOMENT
THANK YOU. DESCRIBING THE LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT. BY NUMBER
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN ALTON FROM GOOD TO KNOW
PARTNERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT SPEECH AT EIGHT THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT
A MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION- LISTED SO
WE'LL GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEING NO ONE HERE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE MATTER
MODERATOR BACK TO YOU IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE QUEUE I
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AGAINST
HER IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ZERO.
PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. ONE
MOMENT I'M SURE WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON SHOWING UP THANK YOU.
DESCRIBING A LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT. ONE MOMENT ENSURE
GRABBING A LINE NUMBER. IN LINE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURSTENFELD AND I AM THE CO
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AND
LEGAL ADVOCACY AT THE CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER. I SUPPOSE THIS
BILL AND MY SKIN IS AMENDED WE
SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY AND TWENTY FOUR
MONTH ELIGIBILITY THESE
PROVISIONS THAT HELP THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. PROBLEM IS THAT
THIS BILL CURRENTLY EXCLUDES
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
WRITERS MAINLY WOMEN OF COLOR
AND THOSE WITH THE LEAST
RESOURCES HAVE CARRIED THE
HEAVIEST BURDEN ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE OFFER
THE FLEXIBLE HOURS THAT HEARING
TEAM ESPECIALLY ESSENTIAL
WORKER AND THEY MUST BE
INCLUDED AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THE FACTIONS WERE INCLUDED
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THE
INDIVIDUAL SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. ARE NOT INCLUDED IN.
MOREOVER THIS BILL IT'S-
REINFORCES THE FAMILY FEAST
THAT PARENTS MUST PAY. THE FEES
KEEP FAMILIES FROM GAINING
MOUTH KEEP THEM FROM BEING
ECONOMICALLY SECURE WE NEED TO
MOVE IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
AND ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR ALL
FAMILY. WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU SECTOR-LIMóN
FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR DAVID-
IT'S A- FAIRLY- YOU KNOW
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE CHILD CARE MORE. IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE. AND I KNOW THAT'S
KIND OF SOUTH OF GOOD MOVE ON
TO HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
WHERE I SIT ON AS WELL I DID
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS THAT
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HELP CLARIFY
FOR ME- SO THIS ESSENTIALLY ONE
OF ONE OF THE ISSUE. WELL THE
THING IS THAT- TO WORK THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WILL
NOW SO SAID DIRECTLY CONTACT
MISTY YEAH THEY CAN CUT- AND-
BASICALLY STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM BE A CONTRACT FOR
SUBSEA ALL AGE SHE OUGHT TO-
BASICALLY TO THE YOUNGER AGES.
BUT I ALSO NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT. THAT THERE
ISN'T. THAT I GUESS THEY'RE
PAYING A STANDARD RATE SO
THERE'S AND SOME INCREASED HEY
THAT NORMALLY BE GIVEN TO
INFANT TODDLER CARE. WHICH OF
COURSE IS MORE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE SMALL
ILL BILL RATIOS AND SO FORTH.
SO THAT I'D BE DECORATIVE YOU'D
THINK YOU JUST ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
PAYMENT IF YOU GO THROUGH THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR
ENSIGN TODDLER CARE THAT.
THEY'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE
CONTRACTS FOR. RIGHT SO THIS.
THE IDEA IS NOT TO RECALL EIGHT
TO ALLOW. FOR THAT POSSIBILITY
FOR THOSE THAT ARE INTERESTED.
I TO CONTRACT THROUGH THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THERE IS A
DIFFERENT BILL GOING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE SB TWO FOUR
SIX. THAT DEALS WAIT. EIGHT
INCREASES- AND THAT IS A
BROADER CONVERSATION IN BETWEEN
ZERO FIVE CARE- AND SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANTED TO SPEAK ON
THAT IT'S NOT MY BILL BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY A PART OF THIS
EQUATION THIS IS ONE OF THE- A
COMBINATION OF BILLS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE-
IT SB YOU FOR SIX. BILL SB
FIFTY AND THEN ALSO AB TWENTY
TWO AT TRY. TO IT WAYS BUT TO
ADDRESSING A MORE HOLISTIC WAY
OKAY APPRECIATE THAT NOW THAT-
AND- APPRECIATE YOU BRING UP
THAT SHOULD BE LOOKING SOME OF
THESE OTHER BILLS- SO BUT BUT
JUST TO CLARIFY YOU DID ASYOU
SAID THAT WAS AT LEAST AS FAR
AS THIS BILL CONCERNED MAYBE
ADDRESS AND AN AND ONE THE
OTHER BILLS IS THAT. IF YOU GO
THROUGH THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM WHICH WAS BEFORE OF
OTHER THREE IN ABOUT THE NOW
IT'S COVERING ALL AGES. THEN
AGAIN A REALIZE IT'S AN OPTION
IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT- THAT IF
YOU DO DO THAT THOUGH THERE
ISN'T AN INK YOU YOU BASICALLY
GET PAID ONE RIGHT NO MATTER
WHAT THE AGES THERE'S NO
INSTANCE DIFFERENCE AND- YOU
DON'T GET INCREASE PAYMENT FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS IF YOU
CHOOSE TO GO THROUGH THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM CORRECT. YOU
KNOW WHAT I NEED TO DEFERRED MY-
TO ANSWER THAT OKAY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU IT AT THE- MS WELCOME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MON SHE HAS
BELIEVE THAT THE RATE FOR
INSTALLERS IS HIGHER THAN IT IS
FOR THREE AND FOUR YEARS OLD
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL AND THAT
WAY WE CAN FOLLOW OUTSIDE
BECAUSE THIS IS AGAIN THIS BILL
WILL BE GOING TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE FENCE SITTING ON AS
WELL SO WE CAN. WILL PUT A PIN
ON THAT ONE. IF I MAY CENTER.
THIS MIGHT HELP ON THAT THE
BILL INCREASES REIMBURSEMENT.
RATES ONLY FOR INFANTS THAT ARE
BEING SERVED BY PRESCHOOL I
BELIEVE. OKAY ALL RIGHT. THE
DETACHED HELPFUL AND AGAIN
MAYBE WE CAN. DIG INTO A LITTLE
MORE AS YOU MENTIONED OR SOME
OTHER BILLS OUT THERE AS WELL
ALL RIGHT. NOW PRE APPRECIATE
THAT- AND THEN THE OTHER.
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT. IT'S
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND SO IN
TERMS OF- BURKE SWITCHING FROM-
DAY SERVE TO AND TO ENROLLMENT
IN TERMS OF PAIN AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU KNOW SO
THAT. YOU DO HAVE FAMILIES
WHERE. THERE NEED FOR CHILD
CARE MAYBE MORE I WANT TO
SPREAD IS A GREAT WORD BUT WHEN
THEY ACTUALLY ACT SIDE ACCESS
IT GIVEN EIGHTY PERHAPS
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES. AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT WE
CAN DO BY ENROLLMENT I
CERTAINLY HEARD THE WITNESS AND
SUPPORT THAT WILL ALLOW THE
OPTION TAKING CARE OF MORE
CHILDREN. I DID JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT WHEN IT COMES. IF
YOU'RE DOING IT BY IN ROME AND-
SO AND ROLL. LOCATOR ONLY
ACCESS IT YOU KNOW A HALF TIME
OR SOMETHING. DOES DAN THIS IS
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDER
REQUIRED TO THE VAN YES I MEAN
DO THEY JUST THAT TO TAKE ON.
SOME MORE DAYS WITH ANOTHER
CHILD OR DO THEY JUST KEEP THE
MONEY AND BECAUSE THEY HAVE X.
NUMBER ROMAN EVEN THOUGH SOME
OF THE PEOPLE AND ROLLED ARE
ONLY USING A PORTION. FOR
WHATEVER REASON SO WHICH I TALK
CLEAR FOR HOW THAT WORKS OUT SO
YOU SIT IS ACTUALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ON MORE
CHILDREN BECAUSE SOMEONE MAY
NOT BE USING IT FULL TIME OR
ONLY USING PORTIONS OF TIME
BUT- HOW DOES THAT SORT ITSELF
OUT BUT- YEAH. YES THIS IS
ACTUALLY. A FORMULA THAT THE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND USE IT
IN ORDER TO BECAUSE THERE ARE
ALSO GUIDELINES IN TERMS OF
RATIOS. FOR ALL OF THIS RIGHT
AND SO THEY HAVE TO. UNDERSTAND
IF SOMEONE IS ENROLLED FULL
TIME OR PART TIME. AND WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE RATIOS SO
BOTH PART TIME AND FULL TIME-
ARE POSSIBLE. AND THERE ARE A
REALITY NOW AND- THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THE CASE BUT IT
DOES ALSO HAVE TO ALIGN WITH
THE RATIOS THAT. ARE
APPROPRIATE AND WE'RE NOT
DEALING WITH RATIOS IN THIS
BILL OKAY NOT IT'D AND DEAD BE
INTERESTED IN. HEARING MORE
DETAILS PERHAPS AFTERWARDS- IT
IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU POINTED OUT
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU
HAVE A FAMILY FAMILY THAT HAS
YOUR CHILD AND YOUR CHILD CARE.
STATE YOU'LL FOR WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCES- NEEDED A WORK
SCHEDULE MAYBE THEIR SOCIAL
SITUATION. THEY'RE NOT USING IT
ALL THE TIME YOU HAVE TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN RATIO SO
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU CAN JUST
AUTOMATICALLY TAKE ON ANOTHER
CHILD BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES AT
CETERA ND THEN SO HOW DOES THE
MONEY END UP. YOU KNOW HOW THE
MONEY FLOW CHANGES WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILLS ONE TRYING TO
AND BETTER UNDERSTAND. SINCE
WE'RE MOVING TO ENROLLMENT.
VERSUS SO- IT DIDN'T DEAL IT'S
GOOD AND IT'S- I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S A NEGATIVE CHANGE I
THINK IT PROBABLY IS BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF. INCREASING ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE AND CREATING MORE
ACCESS WHICH IS ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU KNOW YOURSUPPORTERS
ADVOCATE YES SAYING THAT THIS
WOULD CREATE. LIKE TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW THAT OPERATIONALLY
WOULD WORK AND WE CAN PERHAPS-
BUT DISCUSS. THAT AFTER THIS
BILL PASSES AS IT'S MOVING
THROUGH THE PROCESS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SETTLEMENT FOR ANSWER
MY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND BEFORE I ASK YOU TO
CLOSE SAN RAMON I THINK MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL IS
THAT. THE PROVIDER WOULD KEEP
THE MONEY AND THE SLOT WOULD
STAY THERE SO THAT THE CHILD
WOULD HAVE ACCESS I BELIEVE
IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID-
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHERE.
SOMEBODY CHILD CARE CENTERS
LOST ENROLLMENT- BUT WE KNEW
THIS STUDENTS FOR- OF THE
CHILDREN GOING TO COME. THIS WE
WANT MAKE SURE THE PRIEST FOR.
SO THAT THEY- CAN WELCOME THOSE
BACK I THINK THAT MY- HELP A
LITTLE BIT AND- SENATOR LET ME
KNOW I'M WRONG. AND PLEASE CALL
WHEN YOU'RE READY. ET I MANAGER
YOU'RE CORRECT IN THAT IT
PROVIDES DISABILITY RIGHT ONCE
WE KNOW. THAT SAYS WHETHER IT'S
YOU KNOW FULL TIME OR PART TIME
ENROLLMENT THAT STUDENT AND
THEIR FAMILY HAVE THAT SPOT
WHATEVER THAT SPOT IS- AND
THAT'S THE WAY THAT. I EIGHTEEN
KEEPS THE STABILITY. IN AN ERA
WHERE ESPECIALLY GETTING THE
PANDEMIC. WHERE IT'S CHANGED SO
MUCH SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CLARIFYING THAT- AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. DECEMBER LIMóN WE HAVE A
MOTION. ALMOST THANK YOU THE
MOTEL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN. META CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM THREE SB
FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA. AYE
LEYVA AYE OCHO BOAT HI. THE
TROUBLED BY FOR. CORTEZ THE AYE
DALY NO. VALLEY NOW GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE. PAN HI. AN
HIGH. THANK YOU THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE ONE THANK YOU SENATOR.
LIMóN HAVE A GOOD REST OF THE
DAY. NO POORLY DOING ONE TO
AFTER KIDDING SORRY. I DIDN'T
TURN I DIDN'T TURN THE PAGE.
SENATE ALONE WILL BACK IT'S A
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN. IS THAT
A LIMóN IS GOING TO S. B. C.
THIRTY SEVEN FOR C. WHEN YOU'RE
A- THANK YOU SB SEVEN THIRTY SO
AND A LOT OF THE- STUDENT ARE.
ACCESS KNOWN AS KELCE. I HAVE
PROOF UNDERSTAND ON HOW KELSO
OPERATES IN ITS MISSION PRIOR
TO THE LEGISLATURE I WORKED FOR
THE KELSO PROGRAMMING IN MY
DISTRICT ASSISTING STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ON HOW THEY CAN
ACHIEVE HIGHER EDUCATION. THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND WORKSHOPS
READ CENTRAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE- ENTER STANDING ABOUT
FINANCIAL PASSED FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS. THIS BILL UPDATE THE
STATUTE TO REINFORCE THE
PROGRAM'S FUNCTIONS JUST
SERVICE FINANCIAL AID AWARENESS
LITERACY AND ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THE CURRENT GOVERNING
STATUTE OF KELSO HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE ITS CREATION AND
ITS MODERNIZATION IS ESSENTIAL
TRIPS LIKE THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS TODAY. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO EXPAND THE QUALIFYING
PEOPLE CRITERION RECOGNITION OF
THE DAY FIRST NEEDS EVERY
STUDENT POPULATION. CURRENTLY
THE KELSO PROGRAMMES CONSIST OF
SIXTEEN REGIONAL PROJECTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
DISCOUNTS ARE PROJECTS HAVE
STATUTORY MANDATE TO IMPROVE
THE HIGHER EDUCATION BY RAISING
THE ACADEMIC ELIGIBILITY
UNDERSERVED. STUDENT
POPULATIONS. WITH ME TODAY
MILLER BAR I JUST AND WITH THE-
STATE EIGHT. AND YOU SAID
FINANCE OF KELSO AND- TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER WE WILL GO TO LEAD
SUPPORT MS BARTON ARE YOU READY.
YES I AM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBER THEM
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS
MELISSA BARTO LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION HAD CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE. SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WHAT UPDATE
THE STATUTORY FUNCTIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS PROGRAM ALSO FOR
SHORT A PROGRAM OF THE
COMMISSION HAVE OPERATED FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS. ALSO CONSIDER
SIXTEEN REGIONAL. WITH THE
STATUTORY MANDATE TERM GROUP
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION BY
RAISING THE ACHIEVEMENT LEVEL
AND COLLEGE ELIGIBILITY
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. WILL BE
BOTH ARE IMPORTANT THERE ARE
NUMEROUS GOVERNMENT FUNDED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS AVERAGE TRIO
AND EUROPE THE ALREADY PROVIDE
THE SERVICES AND ARE WORKING TO
CLOSE THE OPPORTUNITY GAP IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD HELP TO RE
PROVISION ACOSTA PROGRAM AT THE
STATE'S PRIMARY FINANCIALLY TO
WEAR AND I THOUGHT I THINK THE
PROGRAM. AND AVOID. DUPLICATIVE
THE AVERAGE FOR. OVERALL OUR
WHEN I SEVEN SEVEN UP THE FACT
YOU COVER CAL. TO REFLECT THE
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO HELP
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
UNDERSTAND THE TRUE COST OF
COLLEGE UNDERSTAND THEIR
FINANCING OPTIONS AND APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID USING A BAFTA OR
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION. BOTH BACK TO TORY
AMENDMENTS ALSO IN TO MAKE
PROGRAM ABOUT UA ATION AND DATA
COLLECTION KEEP ALERT OF CAL.
MORE REGULAR AND CONSISTENT
PROGRAM EVALUATION THAT IS
DRIVEN BY CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT A STUDENT HOW COME
WHEN SURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY
ENROLL IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION WITH FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. THE COMMISSION ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL VERY
TIMELY CONSIDERING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
RECENT LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS THAT
WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO CONFIRM THAT HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR COMPLETE ABOUT FOUR OR
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATIONS. FURTHERMORE IN
RECOGNITION OF THE GROWING
BASIC NEEDS CRISIS AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS IT'S CLEAR TO
US THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE OVERALL
COST OF ATTENDANCE. IF CRISIS
HAS ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE COBRA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
I'VE DEMONSTRATED BY OUR
CORPORATE NINETEEN STUDENT
SURVEY WHICH FOUND THAT SEVEN
IN TEN STUDENTS OFF SOME OR ALL
OF THEIR INCOME. COLLEGE COSTS.
TO BE A CHALLENGE FOR STUDENTS
UNTIL WE HOPE THAT THE COST OF
PROGRAM CAN REFOCUS THE APRS ON
FINANCIAL AID AWARENESS. TO
ENSURESTUDENTS ENTER POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION BUT THE
KNOWLEDGE AND RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO BE THE ACTUAL. MANY OF
OUR HOUSE UP FOR ALREADY MOVING
IN THIS DIRECTION AND
RECOGNITION OF THE CHANGING
NEEDS AND DEMOCRATS. OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION THANKS FOR.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE NOT GOING TO MISS
PLAYERS PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS HE SAID
BIAS AND I AM THE PROJECT
DIRECTOR OF THE KELSO BELLY
PROGRAM. UPLIFTED AN
OPPORTUNITY AN ACTIVE PROGRAM
IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES. A LOS
ANGELES POLICE ARE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO
LIVE IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. WE ALSO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
THE COUNSELORS AND STAFF BETTER
CULPABILITY SCHOOL. MANY OF
WHOM ARE OVERSTRETCHED AND
OVERWHELMED. WE SUPPORT
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOL BY
PROVIDING ONE ON ONE COLLEGE
ADVISING AND AN ARRAY OF FINE
ACTUALLY FOLLOW TO SENIORS IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND THROUGH THEIR
FIRST YEAR OF POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. KHALKHAL PROVOCATIVE
THE U. COLLEGE CULTURE THROUGH
THE HIRING OF UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE STUDENTS TO PROVIDE
MENTORS OR COACHES TO THE
STUDENTS ARE BY THE PROGRAM.
THE SENSE OF COMMUNITY AND
TRUST OF KELSO POSITIONS AS
WELL TO BE THE FINANCIALLY
RESOURCE THAT OUR STUDENTS OF
DESPERATELY NEED AND DESERVE.
FIGURING OUT HOW TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO BE A
LEADING BARRIER TOO MANY OF OUR
PROMISING STUDENTS. THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE FASTER AND
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION ALSO DETER MANY
FROM PICKING EIGHT DESPITE
BEING ELIGIBLE. AREAS TO
FINANCIALLY CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
LEVERAGING HELPFUL FINANCIALLY
TO REPEAT. EVERY FOCUSING TELCO
PROJECT TO BECOME THE STATE'S
LEADING FINANCIALLY AWARENESS
LITERACY INITIATIVE PROGRAM.
UNDER SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN CAL
POLY WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INCREASE FINANCIALLY TO
POTENTIAL COMPLETION. OF MIDDLE
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
WITH TARGETED COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY WORKSHOPS. AND
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CASH FOR
COLLEGE LAB WE PROVIDE
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY.
LASTLY IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT IT
BE SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN PM ACTED
TO HELP STUDENTS NAVIGATE THE
FINANCIALLY PROCESS AND
GRADUATE WITH LESS STUDENT
DEBT. AND IN TURN HELP INCREASE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GOING
POPULATION. FOR THESE REASONS
ARE YOU ARE YOU ALL TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING THAT WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO OUR TELEPHONE
LINES MADAME MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THOSE WHO DO.
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF WISH TO
BE AT THE- OF S. SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. COULD PRESS ONE ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER THE PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. WE DO HAVE
THREE IN Q. MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU. BINA FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS PATHOLOGY
ENOUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ALAN
HUBBARD ON WITH WIDENING GROUP
ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE LISTED AS
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE WILL GO
TO ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. CENA
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE THERE
MADAM MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE
COMING UP WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THE MANAGER.
PLEASE DON'T MIND IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THAT'S ONE
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER IN PLACE TO BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THING THERE ARE NOW. BUT WE DO
HAVE ONE PERSON SHE MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU. BLIND NUMBER THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FORMER
MANAGER. NUMBER THIRTY THREE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT THIS MOMENT I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE CAN SHOOT KAMALA
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR PAM PLEASE
PROCEED I THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU CENTER THE MAN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I KNOW THE
KELSO PLAYS A VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE IN PROVIDING THAT
ASSISTANCE TO STUDENTS ARE
SEEKING FINANCIAL AID. AND
THROUGH THIS FAIRLY CHALLENGING
PROCESS NOW I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THERE'S ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT
USES VOLUNTEERS TO CASH FOR
COLLEGE. PROGRAM CAN YOU SPEAK
TO. WELL- WHAT'S BEING DONE.
WITH TERMS OF INTEGRATING THE
TWO SO THAT THERE. ISN'T
DUPLICATIONS AND OTHER
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND THAT'S
KELSO PUES YEAH THAT THAT JOSH
PARRIS RELIES ON VOLUNTEERS
WHICH CAN BE LESS. STABLE BUT
KEY TO SPEAK TO. HOW WE CAN
READ MINIMIZE DUPLICATION ARE
EVEN DO YOU BRING TO PROGRAM
TOGETHER IN SOME WAY SO AND
THEN HAVE A VOLUNTEER
COMPONENTS- THAT THAT SAYS
SIMILAR CASH FOR COLLEGE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR AND I
ACTUALLY USED TO RUN THE CASH
FOR COLLEGE WORKSHOP IN SANTA
BARBARA SOUTH NUMBER COUNTY
WHEN I WAS RECORDING BURKE
KELSO SO I KNOW A LOT ABOUT
THEM. AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
IS THAT THERE ARE SIXTEEN
REGIONAL KELSO. AND IT STANDS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT IN EVERY
STATE IN EVERY REGION IN SOME
REGIONS YOU WILL SEE CAL SO
TAKE THE LEAD AND OTHERS YOU
HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE UPWARD BOUND
YOU HAVE VOLUNTEERS THEY'RE
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE HIGHER ADD. ON BUT
THIS IS ACTUALLY AN INITIATIVE
I THAT IS NOT A STANDALONE
INITIATIVE THERE'S NOT ONE
PERSON OR ONE ENTITY LEADING-
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE REGION
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS DUPLICATION I THINK THE NEED
FOR. INFORMATION FOR FINANCIAL
AID IS SO. IMPORTANT AND IT IS
REALLY WE'RE NOT NEEDING- DID
YOU KNOW ARE NOT. EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT WAY THAT WE- STILL I
DON'T SEE A WHOLE LOT OF
DUPLICATION CASH FOR COLLEGE IS
ALSO IS A ONE TIME SNAPSHOTS.
RIGHT THAT HAPPENED TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS MEET
THE MARCH SECOND DEADLINE
FINANCIAL LITERACY I THINK
HAPPENS IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS WE'RE TRYING TO HIT. YOU
KNOW HIGH SCHOOLS GOING TO THE
HIGH SCHOOLS THEMSELVES I'M
DOING SOME OF THIS WHILE
STUDENTS ARE THINKING ALREADY
ABOUT THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
STILL THERE. IN MY OPINION-
FROM WHAT I'VE LIVED IN SCENE
THERE'S NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
DUPLICATION. THESE ARE JUST
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES THAT APPLY
DEPENDING ON THE REGION AND HOW
TO MAXIMIZE. THE MOST NUMBER OF
WHAT WE YOU KNOW LEADER CALLED
POSITIVE HIT THE MOST NUMBER OF
HITS WITH STUDENTS. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT ANSWER I
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
PERSONAL EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA
AND SO THE TREMENDOUS RESPECT
FOR THAT AND SO I SEE SOME OF
THE BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE CENTER
PAN DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MAN CONSULTANT- I'M
SO SORRY. FEDERAL MOTOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M JUST
MOVING TO FULL ON TO QUICKLY
TODAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I LOVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
NOW WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PAM. MENTAL CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM FOR SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. HI
THEY'VE AYE PHOTO ABODE. THE
TROUBLE BY COURTESY I PRETEND
THE AYE DALY. GLAZER LASER I
MCGUIRE PAN HI PAM NOT THE BILL
HAS FIVE BUT WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER DOLLY SAN
RAMON THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
NOW YOU CAN HAVE A NICE DAY.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO SB THIRTY FOUR
CENTER- BURKE WHO IS HERE READY
TO GO WELCOME SENATOR UMBERG
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL A
PARTICULARLY- LYNN LORBER ON
EDUCATION STAFF THANK YOU- I'M
HONORED PRESENT SB THIRTY FOUR
A BILL WHICH WOULD IMPROVE
LITERACY ACROSS CALIFORNIA BY
CREATING LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC LIBRARIES. I DON'T NEED
TO EXPLAIN ALL OF YOU THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN FACED
IN EDUCATION MAKING SURE YOUNG
PEOPLE. AREN'T LEFT TOO FAR
BEHIND DURING THE PANDEMIC WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS THIS BILL IS
AN EFFORT TO MERGE TWO OF OUR-
VERY VALUABLE PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS PUBLIC LIBRARIES
AS WELL AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WE DO WHAT WE
CAN THAT TO. ASSIST YOUNG
PEOPLE IN ACCESSING THAT
WONDERFUL RESOURCE OUR PUBLIC
LIBRARIES AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS THIS BILL BILL
WOULD. IN ESSENCE ENCOURAGE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND- PUBLIC
LIBRARIES TO ENTER INTO A
PARTNERSHIP. SO THAT EVERYONE
EVERY SCHOOL AGE CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A LIBRARY CARD-
IT IS AN UNDER UTILIZED
RESOURCE BUT A VERY VALUABLE
RESOURCE. BOB WITH ME-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS MISTER
DAVID NEVIN REPRESENTING SANTA
ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT S.
AND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT. WAS
THE- BASICALLY THE CATALYST FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU BURGER
THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER. MR
NEVIN ARE YOU READY. YES I AM
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
SENATE BILL THIRTY FOUR TODAY
MY NAME IS DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA ANA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. SAUDI AFTER
STUDY SHOWS THAT STUDENTS WHO
DO NOT ACHIEVE READING
PROFICIENCY BY THIRD GRADE ARE
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DROP
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL. OVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
EXACERBATED EXISTING INEQUITIES
WITH REGARD TO STUDENT LITERACY
READING COMPREHENSION AND
ACCESS TO EQUAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. WE BELIEVE SB
THIRTY FOUR IS AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT YOUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTION CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH THEIR
LOCAL LIBRARIES FOR THE BENEFIT
OF STUDENTS. WHILE MAINTAINING
A HIGH LEVEL OF LOCAL CONTROL
BETWEEN THE SCHOOLS AND
LIBRARIES. SANTA ANA UNIFIED
WITH ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH SANTA ANA PUBLIC LIBRARY
AND JUST UNDER NINE MONTHS.
EVEN DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
PROGRAM WENT LIVE JUST TWO
MONTHS LATER EARLIER THIS YEAR.
HUNDREDS OF SANTA ANA UNIFIED
STUDENTS HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
THE- LIBRARY PROGRAM ALREADY.
WE THINK SENATOR ROBERT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL STUDENT
LITERACY AND READING
COMPREHENSION IS THE FOUNDATION
OF EDUCATION WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ARE NO OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO WE'LL
GO HERE TO ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE META
MODERATED TO HAVE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY FOUR CONCERTS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. I WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND TAKE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE DIDN'T THEIR OWN NOW. ONE
MOMENT MANAGER WE HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUING UP. THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN
ROSS- IT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FOUR- THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY TO GET-
LIBRARY CARDS IN THE HANDS OF
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEFORE WE MOVED TO OPPOSITION
CENTER I'M BURKE ARE YOU GOING
TO BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE SUGGEST. YES MANAGER
YES THANK YOU I THOUGHT YOU
WERE BY JUST LIKE CLARIFY THANK
YOU SIR ALL RIGHT. LEAD
OPPOSITION IS ACTUALLY HERE
WITH US OUR CRISTINA DEPLORABLE
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM CRISTINA TO CARL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTY FOUR. FEEL
IS DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF LOCAL CONTROL AND THE
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT THIS BILL
CREATES. PUBLIC LIBRARIES HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT
SEGMENTS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AT ONE POINT LIBRARIES WERE
RECEIVING EIGHTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING. FOR
GENERAL SUPPORT COOPERATIVE
LENDING AND ADULT LITERACY.
GOVERNOR BROWN AND HIS TWO
PREDECESSORS REDUCED IT TO
ZERO. WE STRUGGLE NOW TO EVEN
GET ONE TIME FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET EACH YEAR FOR OUR
PROGRAMS. WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENT TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR TO REQUIRE THE M. AWAY
TO INCLUDE A PROVISION FOR HOW
THE COSTS WOULD BE COVERED
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND THE LIBRARY THIS DOES
LITTLE GOOD WHEN EITHER SIDE
HAS NO MONEY. IN ELDORADO
COUNTY THERE ARE FIFTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND NOT ONE M. AWAY
BETWEEN THE DISTRICT AND THE
PUBLIC LIBRARY. THE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR TELLS US THEIR QUOTE.
MOST OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO
NOT HAVE THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO DO THIS AS THEY
ARE VERY UNDER FUNDED. AND THEY
HAVE VERY LIMITED I. T. TECH
SUPPORT. WE DEFINITELY DO NOT
HAVE THE FINANCIAL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES TO
CREATE AMMO USE. AND CONNECT
WITH OUR FIFTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHOUT FUNDING AND
NEITHER DO THEY END QUOTE. SO
THE REALITY IS THE COST
RECOVERY AMENDMENT IS ONLY
HELPFUL WHEN THERE'S SUFFICIENT
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR BOTH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
LIBRARY. THE COST FOR THE
LIBRARIES UNDER SB THIRTY FOUR
INCLUDE ATTORNEY FEES TO CRAFT
THE AWAY. STAFF RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER THE DATABASE. PRINT
AND DISSEMINATE PR TYPE
MATERIALS WHICH ONE LIBRARY
SAID COSTS TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. CREATION OF THE CARD
ITSELF. TRAINING TEACHERS AND
VISITING THE SCHOOL TO QUOTE
EDUCATE PUPILS. AND ADDING A
NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LIBRARY'S
PERFORM 75% 290% OF THE WORK
FOR THESE PROJECTS. AND WE KNOW
WE WILL GET LEFT HOLDING THE
BAG FINANCIALLY. ONE LIBRARY
DIRECTOR SAID IT BEST FOR THE
LIBRARY IT MAY MEAN WE CLOSE
THE LIBRARY FOR AN HOUR EACH
DAY SO THAT STAFF CAN WORK ON
THE MANDATE. RATHER THAN SERVE
THE LIKE. FINALLY THIS PART.
ARE HAPPENING ALL ACROSS THE
STATE WITHOUT A MANDATE. LOCAL
CONTROL IS CRITICAL BECAUSE
EVERY LOCAL SITUATION IS
DIFFERENT AND EVERY COMMUNITY
HAS DIFFERENT STANDARDS. UNTIL
A BUDGET LINE ITEM CAN BE
CREATED FOR THIS PURPOSE WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
THIRTY FOUR MIKE DYLAN AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER CARRO. WE WILL NOW GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE TELEPHONE
LINES META MODERATED WITH
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THING THERE ARE NOW. AT
THIS MOMENT AND HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR CORTESE
THAN SENATOR PAM. PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER CORTESE. THE
FIGHT THE PODIUM THE FOR ME
CENTER NUMBER- TO SET UP ASKING
YOU TO RESPOND- TO THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS THAT WE
HEARD BUT A JUDGE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE. ONE MINUTE OF CAUGHT
TEXAS DIVIDE PARTICULARLY.
CONCERNED A CAME IN CONCERNED-
AND WE'RE NOT AT THE
APPROPRIATIONS STAGE AT THIS
POINT- BUT JUST. WANTED TO MAKE
SURE I HAVE ANSWERS IN TERMS OF
MY OWN. A DISTRICT MOUNT
CONSTITUENCIES- WE HAVE TO.
BRANCH LIBRARY SO. IN MY
DISTRICT ONE IS THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE'S. MUCH HERALDED BRANCH
LIBRARY SYSTEM WHICH- TO SOME
DEGREE HAS HAS DEEPER POCKETS-
YOU KNOW THEN THEN A LOT OF
LIBRARY SYSTEMS THE OTHER IS
THE COUNTY LIBRARY DISTRICT
WHICH IS A SEPARATE ENTITY AND
RUNS ON A VERY SKINNY BUDGET
ALTHOUGH IT HAS OF A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL BRANCH LIBRARY.
SYSTEM GEOGRAPHICALLY- IT
STRIKES ME THAT IN THE ONE CASE
IT MAY BE VERY DOABLE. WITH THE
CITY PROGRAM WHERE THEY HAVE A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET TO.
TO WORK THIS OUT WITH THE
SCHOOLS- BUT IT STRIKES ME AS-
IT WITHOUT SOME KIND OF GRANT
PROGRAM OR SOMETHING- EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING. FOR THE COUNTY
LIBRARY DISTRICT- UPON WHOSE
BORDER ONCE SAT- TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IN ALONG THE LINES OF THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS WE HEARD-
IT IS IT. I'M SURE YOU'VE STUDY
THIS AND TALK THROUGH IT AND
ARE AWARE OF ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT EXAMPLES THAT ARE OUT
THERE- COULD YOU JUST GIVE US
ANY THOUGHTS ON WHERE YOU THINK
THIS MIGHT BE GOING IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING- FOLKS FROM. YOU
KNOW THE STRAW THE STRAW THE
BREAKS THE CAMEL'S BACK SO TO
SPEAK THAT'S ALL I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT NOT ORDINARILY
THESE KIND OF PROGRAMS GET
WORKED OUT SOMEHOW. FINANCIALLY
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
IN PLACE TO HELP CUSHION THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE RUNNING ON A
THIN MARGIN. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE FOR THAT QUESTION. BOB
FIRST. I THINK IT'S SAD THAT
EVERY SCHOOL AGE CHILD
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE A
LIBRARY CARD I THINK IT'S VERY
SAID THAT THE LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION WOULD BE OPPOSED
TO. HAVING A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OR WHOMEVER
ELSE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EDUCATING YOUNG PEOPLE. SO I
THINK THE COSTS HAVE BEEN
GREATLY EXAGGERATED- THIS
DOESN'T REQUIRE. A DETAILED.
AGREEMENT THE SIMPLY REQUIRES
AN UNDERSTANDING. ALTHOUGH
WRITTEN BETWEEN BOTH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS WELL AS AS WELL AS
A LIBRARY SYSTEM. IT'S NOT THAT
HARD IT'S REALLY NOT THAT HARD-
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY NEED TO
TAKE AN HOUR A DAY AT THE
LIBRARY TO FIGURE OUT HOW. TO
ALLOW SCHOOL CHILDREN TO COME
TO THE LIBRARY. SEEMS LIKE. A
BIT MUCH BOB. IF THERE IS A
COST INVOLVED IF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT- CAN'T AFFORD TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
LIBRARY OR LIBRARY CAN'T AFFORD
TO NEGOTIATE. WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT IT MAY REQUIRE US
TO MAKE IT A BUDGET ITEM IT MAY
REQUIRE US TO AS A MATTER OF
POLICY DECIDE THAT EVERY SCHOOL
AGE CHILD IN CALIFORNIA. SHOULD
BE ELIGIBLE IN SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS. TO LIBRARIES AND SO IF
THAT BECOMES A FACT AND THEN I
WILL DEAL WITH IT ACCORDING TO
ITS WITH SOME SORT OF A BUDGET
REQUEST. BUT RIGHT NOW- WE'RE
WE'RE SIMPLY CREATING A
MECHANISM AND ENCOURAGEMENT
FOR. SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
LIBRARIES TO COME TOGETHER. SO
IF THANK YOU SO THANK YOU
MANAGER. FOR SENATOR PENN THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND
DOESN'T REMEMBER GUYS CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I THINK TRYING TO GET
ACCESS TO LIBRARIES BY DID HAVE
I DID HAVE SOME QUESTIONS MAYBE
I CAN ASK THE OPPOSITION TO
FIRST OF ALL ANSWER QUESTIONS
SO- WHAT DOES IT TAKE. TO GIVE
SOMEONE A LIBRARY CARD. LIKE
WHAT'S INVOLVED FOR THE LIBRARY
TO CENTURY OFFER A LIBRARY CARD
IS IT SIMPLY. WRITE SOMETHING A
PIECE OF PAPER AND THE MINERS
THERE TRACKING USER DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU NEED TO DO
BECAUSE OF SINGLE EVERY CARDIN.
RESULTING ABILITY TO BORROW
MATERIALS I WANT TO SAY BOOKS
ANYMORE SENATE LEVERAGED A LOT
MORE THAN THAT NEED TO SPEAK TO
THE- THE- WHAT. WHAT WE MIGHT
NOT KNOW IS THE PUBLIC IS GOING
ON THE BACK AND TO GET TO OFFER
A LIBRARY CARD. CERTAINLY
CENTER I'LL MY BEST. I CAN YOU
WHEN I COULD WALK INTO A
LIBRARY RIGHT NOW AND REQUEST A
LIBRARY CARD AND WE WOULD GIVE
A VERY BASIC INFORMATION ARE
NAME ADDRESS ETCETERA. THE
LIBRARIES TRY TO KEEP AS LITTLE
INFORMATION ON FILE ABOUT YOU
AS POSSIBLE INCLUDING YOUR
CIRCULATION RECORDS. WHERE HE
GETS INTO THE ISSUE OF- THE
AGREEMENTS. THEN THERE ARE SOME
VERY DELICATE- NEGOTIATIONS
THAT HAPPEN ON A COMMUNITY BY
COMMUNITY BASIS ABOUT WHICH
IDENTIFY YOUR WERE USING FOR
THAT CHILD- THERE. IS REFERENCE
IN THE LEGISLATION TO THE
STUDENT SUCCESS THERE IS
STUDENT IDENTIFIER NUMBER. AND
THAT IS THE NUMBER THAT HAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF DATA.
THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CHILD THAT IS MAINTAINED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THAT DATA AT SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS DON'T WANT TO
HANG ON TO THAT DATA ECAUSE OF
FEAR OF CYBER ATTACKS AND
BREACHES IN SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE TOLD US. WE
DON'T WANT YOU TO USE THAT
INFORMATION SO SOME OF THE
DANCE IS WHAT WHAT NUMBER ARE
WE GOING TO USE A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE TO USE THE
NUMBER THAT FOLLOWS THE CHILD.
THROUGH THEIR THEIR CLASS
RESIDENTS ARE ACTUALLY IN A NEW
SOUND AT THIS TIME YOUR TRIP
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF TIMES TIME
I AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE BURDEN IS ON THE
LIBRARY FOR SUCH A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT HERE'S A LIST OF
STUDENTS BEHALF. AND EAT FIBER
MIGHT GO BACK AND SAY WHAT WE
NEED WHAT MINIMUM INFORMATION
THAT USER LIBRARY WE NEED TO
OFFER A CARD. SO WHAT WORK
DOESN'T INVOLVE THE LIBRARY TO
THEN OFFER A CARD. TO THE LIST
OF STUDENTS. THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT PROVIDE. YES SEOUL
THESE. AND THE LIBRARY MAKE AN
AGREEMENT AS TO WHAT DATA
THEY'RE GOING TO IMPORT AND
THEN THE LIBRARY NEEDS TO
IMPORT THAT DATA. AND IN SOME
CASES IN SOLANO COUNTY IT TOOK
EIGHTY HOURS TO IMPORT THAT
DATA INTO THEIR SYSTEM TO
CREATE THE NEW LIBRARY CARDS.
AND THEN UNDER THIS BILL THERE
WOULD BE COLLATERAL INFORMATION
AT THE LIBRARY WOULD TAKE TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO SAY AND
THESE ARE THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT YOU CAN USE. TO
ACCESS THOSE CARDS. OKAY AND
THEN MONTHLY UPKEEP ON WHAT I
WANTED TO TAKE EIGHTY HOURS
IZZARD SIMPLYA DATA I. T.
ISSUE OR IS IT ACTUALLY. AND
THEN IT DEPENDS UPON THE UNDER
THE LOCAL AGREEMENT. IF THERE
WAS A DECISION TO DO OPT OUT OR
OPT IN VERY WARM- AND THEY HAVE
TO A COLD THE OLD OKAY
SOMEBODY'S GOT AN EXISTING CARD
VERSUS NOW THIS NEW CAR THE
COMPANY ADDED SO DO YOU HAVE TO
CHECK FOR DUPLICATION EXAM
IVORY HAD A CARD BECAUSE WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNGER PARENTS SIGN
THEM UP FOR ONE CENTER OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. SAID THAT AND THEN I
GUESS CENTER I'M BURKE TOOK IT
AT I KNOW THAN THIS BILL YOU
REFER TO THIS IS STUDENT
SUCCESS CARD IS THERE ANY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE STUDENT
SUCCESS CARD AND A LIBRARY CARD
I JUST TRY IT CLARIFIES THERE.
DIDN'T AND BECAUSE YOU'RE
CALLING IT SOMETHING DIFFERENT
IN YOUR BILL. IS THERE ANY
DIFFERENCE ARE THERE EXACTLY
THE SAME THING WITH A DIFFERENT
NAME. WE'RE NOT WEDDED TO A
PARTICULAR TITLE IT'S SIMPLY A-
DOCUMENT OR A NUMBER THAT GIVES
YOU ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC
LIBRARY OKAY SO YOUR INTENT IS
ESSENTIALLY IT'S A LIBRARY CARD
BACK IN OKAY LET ME JUST. SAY I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU EVER
SIGNED UP A CHILD OR YOURSELF
FOR LIBRARY I WE JUST SIGNED UP
OUR GRANDDAUGHTER I DON'T KNOW
THREE YEARS AGO IN. WAS VERY
COMPLICATED PROCESS BECAUSE
YOU'D LOSE YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
ADDRESS IS WELL AS THE ADULT SO
THAT WAS YOU KNOW IT TOOK QUITE
A BIT OF TIME TO FILL OUT. I'M
BEING A BIT SARCASTIC AS YOU
CAN TELL SO THAT THAT WAS WHAT
WAS REQUIRED DIG TO GET A
LIBRARY CARD OKAY ALL RIGHT-
RIGHT NOW I APPRECIATE THAT AND
DE DO YOU DO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT- HAVING DON'T.
TEND THE WORKING WITH MY LOCAL
LIBRARIES AND SO FORTH THAT-
DEPOSITION I KNOW CENTER
CORTESE I ALSO NOTED THIS
BILL'S GOING TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE BEFORE GOES
APPROPRIATIONS I HOPE THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO BETTER ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS I THINK
THERE'S GONNA E MAYBE A
QUESTION ABOUT APPROPRIATIONS
WELD GIVE AND- IF THERE'S ADDED
ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON TO.
LIBRARIES ARE LIBRARIES ARE
PRETTY. SHORT HANDED- SO I AND
THEN THEN SO HOPE WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT AS BEFORE. BILL TO
THE FULL BUT I. WHY I DO SHARE
YOUR GOAL AND WANT TO SEE. YOU
DIVVIED UP TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS AND- HOPEFULLY WE CAN-
NO DEAL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT OPPOSITION BROUGHT
UP SO THAT. WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN MORE UNIVERSALLY ITEMS I
KNOW THAT MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RATE DOING THIS WITH THEIR
LIBRARIES THE CHALLENGES THAT
THE ONES WHO AREN'T WHY AREN'T
THEY DOING IT AND WHAT APPEARS
WE HAVE TO TACKLE SO THAT. WE
CAN DO IT EFFECTIVELY AND- NOT
CNSTRAIN THE LIBRARY OR TO
SCHOOL IN TERMS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO FIGHT OTHER. TO
OTHER SERVICES AND LIMITED
ACCESS TO OTHER PARTS OF PUBLIC
SO THANKS VERY MUCH US IN A
BURKE. BIG CENTER PANTS UNDER
GLAZER. THANK YOU- CENTER I'M
BURKE AT THE LOVE OUR SCHOOLS
LOVE OUR LIBRARIES THINK EVERY
WITH EVERY KID SHOULD HAVE A
LIBRARY CARD SO THOSE ARE ALL
EASY YES YES YES FROM FOR ME-
WHEN HE DESCRIBED THE BILL
THOUGH IT LEFT ME A LITTLE
CONFUSE YOU USE LANGUAGE AT THE
START THAT SAYS ALLOWS. AND
THEN- IN ANSWER TO A QUESTION
OR A FEW MOMENTS AGO YOU SAID
ENCOURAGES. BUT IS THIS A
MANDATE OR NOT A MANDATE YES-
THIS IS A- ITWILL ULTIMATELY
BE A MANDATE AND WHETHER WE
NEED TO APPROPRIATE MONEY WE
MAY NEED TO APPROPRIATE MONEY
UP TO COOLEY OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND LIBRARIES CAN'T.
ACCOMMODATE THIS- REQUIREMENT
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET- AND IT'S
A POLICY QUESTION IS A PRIORITY
QUESTION DO WE THINK THAT EVERY
SCHOOL AGE CHILD SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE WONDERFUL
INSTITUTIONS THAT MIGHT BE ARE
BEING UNDER UTILIZED IN THE
STATE OKAY FOR WITH RESPECT
THIS IS A MANDATE WOULD ALTER
THE BILL'S GOING TO SAY TO MY
LIBRARIES I MEAN IS IT TRUE
THAT MY LIBRARIES IN MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT COULD WORK THIS OUT
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT CORRECT ABSOLUTELY OKAY SO
THIS IS FORCING EVERY LIBRARY
EVERY SCHOOL TO COMPLY WITH
THIS EVEN THOUGH THEY COULD DO
THIS RIGHT NOW JUST BY
COMMUNICATING BECAUSE- WHO IN
THE LIBRARY COMMUNITY WOULDN'T
WANT TO ALL THEIR STUDENTS IN
THEIR AREA TO HAVE A LIBRARY
CARD. AND WHAT SCHOOL WOULDN'T
WANT TO HAVE ALL THEIR KIDS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE ARRAY OF
MATERIALS AT A LOCAL LIBRARY
RIGHT TO THE END WAS EITHER
VERY YEARS WHAT'S WHAT'S
CREATING THE NEED FOR THIS
MANDATE IS MUCH OF THAT SO
WONDERFULLY IT COMES FROM THE
HEART AND YOUR SPONSORS IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING TO DO BUT WE'LL
HAVE WHY IS STATE MANDATE
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO OVERCOME. THE PROBLEM DANCE
YOUR QUESTION YES THERE ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND LIBRARIES
THAT HAVE NOT COME TOGETHER AND
US THERE ARE CHILDREN WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO LIBRARIES AS
THEY SHOULD- FOR WHATEVER
REASON BECAUSE OF A LANGUAGE
BARRIER OR BECAUSE OF FOR
EXAMPLE A SOME SORT OF A
CULTURAL BARRIER IN MY OWN
AREA- ESPECIALLY ACUTE DURING
THE PANDEMIC IS HIS ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET MOST CHILDREN IN
MOST SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE HARDWARE BUT
SOMETIMES THE INTERNET.
CONNECTIVITY DOESN'T EXIST IT
DOES EXIST IN LIBRARIES AND SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE MAKE IT A
PRIORITY WE HAVE TO FUND THAT
PRIORITY- OF MAKING SURE THAT
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA. HAS
ACCESS TO PUBLIC LIBRARY. AND
IF WE HAVE TO FOR IT THEN. IT
BE MY THAT WOULD BE A PRIORITY
AND THAT WE SHOULD APPROPRIATE.
THE FUNDS TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
OKAY. AND I HEARD YOU SAY THAT
YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS BUT
YOU KNOW I HAD TROUBLE
FOLLOWING EXACTLY WHAT. THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD YOU BE
CLEAR TO US NOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS YOU ARE
ACCEPTING. ON THIS BILL- IT
BEGINS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS TO GET YOU GET YOU GO
ON BUT. THE- THE- AMENDMENT TO
REQUIRE THE AGREEMENT TO FOR
EXAMPLE PROVIDE FOR SOME SOURCE
OF FUNDING SO THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE ALLOCATION SO THAT
DOESN'T REMAIN AMBIGUOUS- I
BELIEVE WE ALSO- BUT WHAT HE
SAID IN A POSITIVE WHAT IS YOUR
BILL DUE TO RESPOND TO THE
SAVANNAH. WHAT IS MY BILL DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WHAT IS
YOUR BILL DOING TO RESPOND TO
THESE A MEMBER REQUEST WHAT
EXACTLY ARE YOU MANY YOUR BILL
TO DO THAT. JUST TO BE CLEAR-
CENTER GLAZER I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TALK WITH YOU OFFLINE I'LL GO
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS IF YOU
WILL- I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY.
WHAT THE COPY DOES TO OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE BILL BUT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO OFFLINE.
CHECK FOR BECAUSE FOR ME IT- I
APPRECIATED THE SSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BUT I I'M LEFT WITH
A LITTLE CONFUSION IS. IT
REGARDING EXACTLY HOW YOU
REMAIN IN THE BILL TO DO WHAT I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE DECIDED
THAT THIS BILL IS TO DOUBLE
REFERS. AND THAT PERHAPS IT HAS
A DEAL HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
CLEAR SOME OF THOSE THINGS UP.
BUT I AM TROUBLED THAT OUT OF
THIS GOODNESS. OF YOUR HEART
AND OTHERS THAT TO HAVE OUR
KIDS HAVE LIBRARY CARDS HAVE
ACCESS THE SITUATION MATERIAL
THAT. WE'RE REALLY. NOT WILL
COVER CREATING THIS MANDATE AND
YET YOU KNOW. WE'RE KIND OF
CALL IT A MANDATE OR KIND AND
NOT AND WE'RE NOT REALLY PAYING
FOR IT. AND SO OUT OF THIS YOU
KNOW GOOD YOUR GOOD OF GOOD
DIRECTION I HAVE I'VE WORRIES
AND CONCERNS AND I HOPE THAT
YOU CAN WORK THEM OUT I'M
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD TODAY TO ALLOW YOU THAT
OPPORTUNITY. BUT WHEN YOU WE
MAKE THESE KINDS OF STATE
MANDATES I THINK WE HAVE TO TRY
TO BE. CLEAR THERE WERE
OVERCOMING A PROBLEM- NOT
NESTLE RELUCTANCE BUT A REAL.
AND THINK OF A GOING TO CREATE
A MANDATE THAT WE- HAVE TO OWN
UP TO IT AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR GOOD HEARTED TAKEN
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS CENTER
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
TO HAVE A QUESTION ON THE- SO
WE'VE DONE SANTA ANA. IN HAS
ALREADY DONE THIS RIGHT CORRECT
IT'S BEEN EMPLOYERS THURMOND
SANTANA DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
BACK ON LIKE HOW MANY. MORE
LIKE. WHAT THE PERCENTAGE OF.
STUDENTS ACTUALLY ACCESSED AND
USED IT AND- THEN DID IT
INCREASED TO. STAY THE SAME OR
DO YOU HAVE SOME DATE ON THAT I
DIDN'T SEE THAT ANY OF THIS
STUFF I WAS PROVIDED- LET ME
REFER TO MR NEVIN. TO SEE IF
MISTER NEVINS TO ONLINE APPEARS
DATA. MISTER NEVER. ENTERED
ALWAYS- THE PROGRAM WAS ONLY
FULLY IMPLEMENTED ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF TO FOUR MONTHS AGO.
SO I CAN CERTAINLY CONNECT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF WITH THE- THE
HEAD LIBRARIAN BACK. YEAH
MANAGES THE DATA AND THE
PROGRAM BETWEEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE LOCAL SANTA
ANA PUBLIC LIBRARY AND PROVIDE
YOUR STAFF WITH. IN YOUR OFFICE
WITH THAT THERE. PERFECT THANK
YOU SO I HAVE. ISN'T SORRY I
LOOK THIS BILL SO I BUY AS MANY
YOU KNOW I SERVED. A VERY LONG
TIME ON COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I WAS AROUND
THE DAYS WHEN THEY DE FUNDED
LIBRARIES I MEAN. THIS STATE
USED TO HELP OUT IN THE STOP
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY.
YARDS CELLS WE'VE HAD TO KEEP
OUR LIBRARIES OPEN IN OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES AND- IT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
LIBRARIES ARE CRITICAL TO
EDUCATION TO. THE BILL YOU TO
READ AND- MORE IMPORTANTLY I
THINK TO ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
EXPECTATIVA FORTY WHERE WE HAVE
VERY LIMITED. BROAD AND WE'VE
WORKED I KNOW THIS THE
LEGISLATORS WORKED ON. A MANY
BILLS- AND I'VE PARTICIPATED
KNOWS TO GET BROADBAND OUT TO
THOSE- RULE COMMUNITIES. AND WE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE FUNDED IS IT
HASN'T REALLY ENDED UP THERE IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR- HOSPITALS
IN THE IN THE LIBRARIES. WITH
THAT BEING SAID- I HAVE ELEVEN
COUNTIES AND I HAVE THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS GEOGRAPHIC
WISE IN THE STATE AND MANY OF
THESE SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CLOSE LIBRARIES OR MAYBE ONE
OF THE COUNTY SEAT SO FOR
EXAMPLE. BEAVERS SEVENTY FIVE
MILES FROM THE COUNTY SEAT
THERE'S A LIBRARY THERE WE DO
HAVE A LIBRARY IN OUR
COMMUNITY- BUT IS STAFFED BY
VOLUNTEERS RIGHT ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THE SCHOOL THE
SCHOOL HAS ACCESS CAN GO OVER
TO THE LIBRARY ANYTIME IN THE
STUDENTS DO I DID WHEN I WAS
THERE- BUT TO MANDATE THE
SCHOOL HOW WOULD IT WORK OUT
WHAT WHAT'S YOUR VISION FOR
THIS. IN THESE VERY RULE
COMMUNITIES WHERE IN MANY CASES
THERE IS NO LIBRARY EXCEPT FOR
IF THERE IS ONE IT MAY BE-
LITERALLY. OVER FIFTY MILES
AWAY. SENATE DOLLY I WOULD
EXPECT IF THERE'S NO LIBRARY
WITHIN FIFTY MILE RADIUS THAT-
IN TERMS OF THE PARENTS
INTEREST IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING SOME
SORT OF ACCESS THAT THEY WOULD
WORK IT OUT WHERE ONE WOULD
HAVE A CARD AND PEOPLE WANT TO
TRAVEL THAT FIFTY MILES THEY
THEY CAN DO SO OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T REQUIRE THIS DEVILISH
MINIMAL LIBRARY JUST PROVIDES
THAT. IF A LIBER EXISTED THAT
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO LIVE LIBRARY. AUGUST
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY I THINK IF WE
REALLY WANT TO DO SOMETHING
THAT HELPS. STUDENTS GET A
LIBRARIES WE WOULD HELP FUND
LIBRARY SO THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
TO GO TO IN IN MY CASE IRAN ARE
COUNTIES CASES- I CAN TELL YOU
THERE'S VERY LITTLE ACCESS-
JUST BECAUSE THERE'S REAP
REALLY A LACK OF FUNDING. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY. SIR I'M BURKE BEFORE I
ASK YOU TO CLOSE I HAVE A
COUPLE COMMON TO MY OWN. FIRST
I WOULD SAY I WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED TO FIND SOMEONE WHO
LOVES LIBRARIES MORE THAN
IDEAL. WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL
I GOT TO GO MY FIRST TIME IN
KINDERGARTEN AND I WENT ALL
THROUGHOUT MY- GRAMMAR SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL YEARS AND I
ALWAYS FELT LIKE IT WAS SUCH A
PRIVILEGE. TO GET TO GO AND
CHECK OUT A BOOK OR MY PARENTS
COULDN'T AFFORD ENCYCLOPEDIAS
AT THE TIME- WE NOW USE THE
INTERNET. AND TO GET TO GO AND
USE THE ENCYCLOPEDIA'S- FOR ME
IT WAS SOMEWHAT LIFE CHANGING
SO WHEN I SAW YOUR BILL I WAS
VERY EXCITED. BUT THEN WHEN I
SAW THAT THE LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION WAS IN OPPOSITION I
THOUGHT. THIS KIND OF RAISES A
RED FLAG FOR ME. AND I THINK
THE ISSUE IS THAT I KNOW
SPEAKING FOR ONLY MY TO MY-
LIBRARIES IN MY SCHOOL MY
DISTRICT. THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY AND YOU KNOW I'VE
WORKED TO FIND FUNDING TO SEND
DOLLARS POINT OF WORK TO FIND
FUNDING FOR MY LIBRARY SINCE
I'VE BEEN ELECTED. MANY OF THEM
HAVE PART TIME STAFF VERY PART
TIME STAFF SO THE EXTRA TIME
THEY NEED TO. TO MAKE THE
LIBRARY CARDS WHAT SEEMS EASY
TO US. WE REALLY BE DIFFICULT
FOR THEM- I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. I DON'T
LIKE TO KILL BILLS IN THE FIRST
POLICY COMMITTEE- AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH LAN. WE WANT
TO TRY TO DO THE BEST WE COULD
TO MAKE SURE WE COULD. COME TO
A RESOLUTION WHERE- THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD SO OF COURSE I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
BUT I HOPE AS YOU MOVE FORWARD.
HE WILL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND YOU KNOW
UNFUNDED MANDATE AS SOMETHING I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT UNTIL I CAME%
HERE TO SACRAMENTO. AND IT'S A
TOUGH ONE SO IF WE NEED TO FIND
FUNDING MAY BE THE BILL DOES
NEED TO BE AMENDED FOR THAT. SO.
I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
US THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
WHERE YOU HEART IS BECAUSE- I
TO THINK THAT LIBRARIES. SO
COOL. AND FOR. REASONS TODAY.
THAN WHEN I WAS A CHILD. SO DO
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
ARCHIES BEFORE THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- URGENT I BUILT.
THANK YOU TO HAVE A MOTION.
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS. THE BILL HOOVER CENTER
GLAZER MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM SEVEN SB
THIRTY FOUR. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE LEYVA BYE. IF I OWE TO
ABOVE NO WHICH OBERG NO
COURTESY. FOR TENNESSEE I'D
DALY WHO DAILY NOW GLAZER.
GLAZER HI MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I.
THE BILL TELEPORTED THINK HE
SAID NUMBER THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU MEMBERS YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
MOMENT. FOR ANYONE HAS
PARTICIPATED TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF YOU YOUR COMMENTS
ARE NOT HEARD TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SEND THEM TO US AND BEFORE WE
ADJOURN I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE BILL THAT. WE NEED TO OPEN
THE ROLE ON AND MANAGING
CONSULTANT WHAT BILL IS THAT. I
AM FOR FEDERAL MON SB THREE
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING ON MY
CENTER DOLLY NO DALY NOW
MCGUIRE. THE BILLS OUT FIVE TO
ONE MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HAVE A GREAT DAY WE'LL SEE YOU
NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOUR OLD.